Müssen wir mal gucken, geht's jetzt?
Ah!
Jetzt geht's.
Also, 6.900
scheinen anscheinend das Größte zu sein, wo man
auf Twitch streamen kann, würde ich mal sagen.
6.900.
So, guck mal, man konnte sich
doch den Kram hier irgendwie anzeigen lassen.
Video-Stats.
Ja, 6.900.
Jetzt haben wir
Huge Quali haben wir am Start.
Guck mal,
der Carsten ist am Start.
Krasse Banger.
Erstmal voll im Stream,
vier Weiber im Swimmingpool.
Aber nice, nice.
Okay, das finde ich gut.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, Leute.
Speed-Test.
Passt mal auf.
Big Brain Time.
Pfeifert. Bam.
Passt auf.
Ups.
Seht ihr das hier?
Pock.
Huge.
Warum sind denn die Emotes heute so groß?
Sieht ja gar nichts.
Hier, 4.025 Mbit.
Massive Pockers.
Und hier, 40 oder 41, 42 ab.
Gut, jetzt buggt es, weil,
ne?
Es laggt ein bisschen, weil ich uploade.
Alles kein Problem.
Call of Duty Problems.
Störungen bei Call of Duty.
Moment, alle Störungen.de
hat eine Seite für Call of Duty?
Warum?
Nur 96, danke.
Was kostet der Spaß?
80 Euro, 98.
Also ich brauche mehr Subs,
dass ich mir das leisten kann.
Easy Subs, easy life.
Also 81 Euro kostet der Kram.
Das ist dabei.
400 Down, 20 ab.
Power Upload macht 40 ab.
Ähm, Fernseh.
Also der Kabel, der Kabel, der Kabel, der Kabel.
Der Kabelanschluss ist dabei.
Ähm, ne gut, Flatrate muss man heute nicht mehr erwähnen.
Fernseh, stell's.
Ich habe heute ein riesen Paket gekriegt von Unity Media.
Und davon habe ich nichts ausgepackt,
außer diese komische Connect Box.
Das ist dieses Teil da.
Und das hat mich,
das hat mich schon mal massive jebaited.
Am Anfang.
You got jebaited.
Das Ding hat mich massive jebaited,
weil ich habe es angemacht.
Habe mich eingeloggt.
Äh, bin halt auf die Adresse.
Und da stand dann da, hey, alles verbunden.
WLAN an, Internet an, sonst was.
Aber online ging nicht.
Äh,
Kolox, oder Krolox?
Stufe 1.
Huge, huge big brain sub.
Ähm, zumindest.
Stand halt da, ich bin online,
alles gut, aber es war nicht online.
Ich konnte nichts pingen.
Und ich habe dann erst gedacht, okay, woran liegt das?
Ich habe ja in der Box von Unity Media, ne,
waren irgendwie drei verschiedene Geräte drin.
Irgendein komischer Verstärker,
wo ich keine Ahnung habe, wozu es gut sein soll.
Irgendeine,
irgendeine komische Box zum Fernsehgucken
und Aufnehmen.
Und halt, und halt das, das, der Router.
Da steht lustigerweise Modem drauf,
was aber eigentlich nicht stimmt, weil das ist ein Router.
Also ein Multifunktionsgerät,
um mal zurückzukommen auf mein Video von,
von vor ein paar Tagen, äh, ist überhaupt kein Modem, ne.
Ist natürlich ein Modem drin, aber es ist noch viel mehr als ein Modem.
Und ich brauche davon nichts.
Ich brauche nur das Modem.
Den ganzen anderen Kram braucht man nicht.
Da ist so ein...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür das hier da ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ver...
Multimedia, Multimedia, Verstärker.
Moment.
Multimedia...
Da kann es mal...
Ver...
Der da...
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich damit soll.
Was ist das überhaupt?
Ja?
So, schwarz ist es bei mir.
Was...
Was ist das überhaupt?
Und wann, wann sollte ich es benutzen?
Das ist kein WLAN Repeater.
Blödsinn, ne.
Hast du eigentlich die Business- oder die Privatvariante?
Ich habe die Privatvariante.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das Ding ist doch zum extrahieren des TV-Signals?
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, also...
Ich habe, äh, meine zwei TV-Karten da dran angeschlossen
und die gehen nach wie vor.
Ohne... Ohne Änderung, ja?
Moin. Deine Meinung, dass bei einer 4K-Leitung abends zu 100
und montags mittags 180 durchgeht, bei mir nicht.
Meinst du bei dir jetzt?
Ja, das sagt natürlich.
Stört dich DS Lite nicht?
Doch, mich stört DS Lite.
Deswegen habe ich auch kein DS Lite.
Mir gibt's kein DS Lite.
Ich habe noch einen kompletten...
Vollwertigen IPv4-Anschluss.
Trotz Upgrade.
Ich habe mir das von denen, vom Upgrade, 50 mal bestätigen lassen,
dass ich IPv4 behalte.
Und war dann auch so am Ende.
Zumindest, ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür das Ding ist.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was man damit macht.
Multimedia-Verstärker.
Brauche ich nicht.
Habe sie nicht angeschlossen, geht auch so alles wunderbar.
Und was ich im Leben nicht anschließen werde, ist das da.
Das war auch dabei.
So eine komische Box.
Von Unity Media.
Ich vermute mal, die ist zum Fernsehgucken.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich mit der machen werde?
Die werde ich auf den Dachboden stellen und nie wieder anrühren.
Die verwende ich nicht.
Salah, crap.
Das einzige, was ich brauche von Unity Media, ist das Modem.
Skat-Anschluss.
Ja, ich meine, ja gut.
Das war überall...
Habe ich das richtig gesehen? Man kann da einen Telefon anschließen?
Oder sehe ich das jetzt falsch?
Telefon? Telefon?
Warum will ich denn an einem Fernseher
einen Telefon anschließen?
Das ist mal Big Brain Time
von Unity Media.
Warum genau will ich im Fernsehen
einen Telefon anschließen?
Das ist Router und Resilvermögen.
Ja, warum? Ich habe doch schon einen Router.
Ich habe doch diese komische Connect-Box.
Okay, was auch immer. Wir hinterfragen das nicht weiter.
Ich werde es eh nicht verwenden.
Und wisst ihr, was richtig nice ist?
Was ich gerade gesehen habe?
Oh, sorry, Leute. Tut mir leid.
Router.
Den Router werde ich nicht verwenden.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich gesehen habe?
Was richtig pockers ist?
Connect-Box
Bridge-Mode
Seit diesem
oder seit ein paar, seit zwei Monaten
oder so, kann man
die Connect-Box im Bridge-Mode betreiben.
Und das heißt,
ich kann einfach
alles mit meinem Mikrotik-Router machen.
Ich weiß zwar noch nicht, wie man das
Ich weiß zwar noch nicht,
wie man das einrichtet,
aber das geht bestimmt.
Das geht bestimmt.
Und dann bin ich komplett
den ganzen Crap von Unity Media los.
Dann ist das einfach nur noch ein stinknormales Modem.
Aber dann
geht, glaube ich, Telefon nicht mehr.
Ich benutze ja auch das Telefon
gar nicht von Unity Media.
Also aktuell habe ich das so.
Ich kann euch das ja mal kurz
erklären, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Ob es funktioniert, sieht man dann natürlich erst
nach ein paar Monaten.
Und zwar, aktuell habe ich,
danke für die Subs, wen haben wir denn hier?
Tainzer, Twitch Prime, huge big brain
play. Fritzi,
14 HD,
auch ein Twitch Prime Sub.
Big brain alle heute.
Und maximale Frames pro Sekunde
natürlich.
Also ich habe
ein paar Unity Media.
Also ich habe einmal Unity Media
Fly 400, da der Name schon
alleine schon, Fly 400.
Da ist dabei,
Kabelanschluss
für 20,99.
Dann Fly, das ist,
der ist noch dabei.
Das ist quasi
Internet
und Fernsehen.
So.
Und dann habe ich für diesen Telefonkrempel
habe ich bei
Easy Bell den kleinsten
den
kleinsten Anschluss, den es gibt.
Nicht Internet
und Telefon, ich will nur Telefon.
Privatkundentelefon.
Das Ding habe ich hier.
Für 2,99 im Monat.
Das habe ich gemacht aus dem Grund,
weil ich keinen Bock habe,
abhängig zu sein von meinem Internet Provider.
3 Play.
Fly 400.
Ja,
Triple, Triple Play.
Triple
Play Fly 400.
Zumindest habe ich mir extra den Kram hier gebucht
und meine Rufnummer dahin portieren lassen.
Weil es ist immer
kacke, seinen Internet Provider
zu wechseln, wenn da auch
automatisch das Portieren der Rufnummer
dranhängt.
Das ist immer mehr Stress, als es irgendwie sein müsste.
Deswegen habe ich es jetzt so gemacht.
Meine Telefonnummer habe ich einmal zu diesem Anbieter
hier portiert.
Ich bezahle 2,99 Euro zusätzlich im Monat.
Und da geht einfach,
ich telefoniere ja nicht viel.
Ich werde auch nicht viel angerufen.
Und dann ist das optimal.
Das kostet 2,99 nochmal oben drauf.
Deswegen kann ich
einfach meine Connect Box,
ist mir gerade eingefallen,
in Bridge Mode setzen.
Die Beta, die ist glaube ich
38 GB oder so.
Oh fuck, ich glaube ich habe meine Festplatte voll gemacht
mit Videoaufnahmen vorher entweder.
Monkeys.
So, und das werde ich morgen mal ausprobieren, glaube ich.
Ich werde den,
ich werde meinen Router umstellen,
äh nicht umstellen, ich werde meine Connect Box
umstellen auf
Bridge.
Wie macht man mit dem MikroTik Router
dann die Einwahl?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Es gibt doch mittlerweile wieder das Modem.
Also ich habe nur,
ich kann ja die Connect Box umstellen
auf Modembetrieb.
Das wäre natürlich am besten.
Da muss ich mir nichts extra nochmal schicken lassen.
Ja okay, wie auch immer.
Keine Ahnung, aber das werde ich mal ausprobieren.
Und dann ist der ganze Crap raus.
Das komische Unity Media Wlan.
Die versuchen
standardmäßig so ein komisches Gäste-Wlan
aufzuschwatzen, wo man dann irgendwelche
Leute, die auf der Straße rumlaufen mit dem Handy
in seinem Wlan drin hat und sowas. Ganz komisches Zeug.
Und alles weg.
Und wenn es sich nicht ausschalten lässt,
dann kommt irgendwie,
dann kommt,
dann kommt die Box in irgendeine
Alu-
Alukiste, wo das
Wlan nicht mehr rausgeht.
Also ich habe keinen Bock,
irgendwie Leute in meinem Wlan zu haben.
Ich habe mein eigenes Wlan.
Aber allein schon, dass die auf meinem Router drauf sind,
ist mir irgendwie nicht so ganz geheuer.
Aluhut, ja.
Der Aluhut kommt auf den Router drauf.
Zelda Tab, leider ist das nicht mehr da.
Die haben das glaube ich gelöscht, das Video hier.
Sieht's Batman.
Contains Nintendo Content.
Ich habe übrigens gerade mit dem Tilo
ein bisschen Modern Warfare gespielt.
Übelst nice Runde. 45...
45...
9 oder so.
Übelst bam bam.
Alles weggeklatscht.
Könntest du das Ding nicht flashen?
Ne, die Connect-Box kannst du nicht flashen.
Die Connect-Box kannst du nicht flashen.
Ja, jetzt wenn ich gerade mal online bin, könnte ich eigentlich mal das
einkaufen, was ich im letzten Stream einkaufen wollte.
10...
Wenn du 10 Mbit Upload hast, ist
vollkommen ausreichend zum streamen.
Vollkommen ausreichend.
Sehr körperbetont irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Grills gibt,
die wirklich so am Strand rumlaufen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass sie ein bisschen zu freizügig am Strand.
Naja, was auch immer.
Eigentlich wollte ich das jetzt nicht bestellen.
Mindestens 25?
Ne, guck mal.
Wenn du streamen willst, du kannst mit viel weniger streamen.
Das Maximum an Bitrate...
Guck mal hier.
Das Maximum an Bitrate, was geht auf Twitch,
ist 6,9 Mbit.
Das reicht locker, was du hast.
Locker.
Ich wollte mir nämlich für mein Nass-Gebastel,
für mein Nass-Selbstbau-Versuchs-Ding,
wollte ich mir einen SATA 3
Port Multiplier kaufen und gucken,
ob das ordentlich funktioniert.
So war es da.
Es geht eigentlich mit der Musik ab.
Passt bei Lautstärke, ja.
Es sollten auch mehr...
Also ich habe es gerade mal gestellt auf 12 Mbit.
Das war zu viel.
So viel ging nicht.
Da hat er runterencoded.
Ich brauche nämlich einen SATA 3 Port Multiplier.
Wenn es das gibt, wäre echt nice.
Das ist nur SATA 2, oder?
SATA 3?
Tatsächlich doch.
Das wäre nämlich echt nice, sowas.
6 Gigabit.
Ja, das ist das Richtige.
Sowas hier wollte ich mir mal bestellen.
Dann brauchen die da Versand nach Deutschland.
Shipping.
Leute, es ist so krass, oder?
Dass du was aus China bestellen kannst
und
es kostet dich aus China
was zu bestellen, 51 Cent.
51 Cent aus China.
Oder alternativ mit DHL
für 34 Euro.
EMS Paket nennen wir dann.
Kommt an am 18.10.
Reicht doch, 3 Wochen, easy.
Oder alternativ mit Turkey Post.
Also quasi
Truthahn.
Das würde ich dann nehmen.
Germany, perfekt.
Kaufen wir gleich mal
4 Stück.
Add Card.
Kann man jetzt nicht einfach so
einen Card adden?
Ja, kann man.
Das ist hardcore subventioniert,
die Versandkosten.
Letztens die USB-Kabel, die ich bestellt habe,
da haben 50 USB-Kabel 46 Euro gekostet,
inklusive DHL-Versand.
Das heißt, ich habe
ein USB-Kabel
1,5 Meter
oder 1 Meter
egal, ist auch scheißegal,
für unter 1 Euro
gekriegt, ist ein Micro-USB-Kabel
mit Adapter dabei
auf USB-C. Für unter 1 Euro.
50, ja.
Bam. 50 USB-Kabel.
Ja, warum denn auch nicht?
Warum
auch nicht?
Ich meine, wer braucht keine 50 USB-Kabel?
Warum 50 Stück?
Weil ich für nächste Zeit
definitiv genug USB-Kabel haben wollte.
Ich wollte einfach nur mal sicher gehen, dass ich nie
out of USB-Kabel
runne.
Merkwürdiges Deutsch.
Der Umwelt zuliebe, das auch.
Ich meine, ich könnte mir 50 mal ein USB-Kabel
bestellen oder einmal 50 USB-Kabel.
Das ist natürlich dann einfach
viel umweltbewusster. So sieht's aus.
Weil ja China
bestellen generell so wahnsinnig
umweltfreundlich ist.
Aber was willst du machen? So was gibt es hier in Deutschland nicht.
Wenn ich bei Amazon.de gucke,
ich habe übrigens immer noch
eine 1TB NVMe SSD
hier rumliegen, die ich noch nicht eingebaut habe.
SATA Port Multiplier
mit
SATA 3
Da gibt es nur so hässliche PCI Express
Dinger, die keiner brauchen kann.
Oder irgendwelche noch billigeren
China Dinger,
die aber auch nur SATA
2 können.
SATA 1,5 oder
genau 3 Gigabit ist SATA 2.
Ist ja auch
voll logisch wieder.
Kennst du einen kostenlosen Web-Hoster?
Ich denke, dass mit 1 DB reichen würde.
Ne, fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht, was es für gute kostenlose Hoster gibt.
Muss man auf Reddit gucken bei Self-Hosted.
Da haben die immer ganz gute Sachen.
Oder du guckst bei Low-End Talk.
Da gibt es immer für ein
Apfel und ein Ei irgendwelche guten Angebote.
Ist da eigentlich ein großer Unterschied
zwischen ASP.NET
und Standard Webform?
Ja, riesen Unterschied.
Standard.NET Webforms verwendet
kein Mensch mehr.
ASP.NET verwendet auch keiner mehr.
Ähm, ASP.NET Core ist das, was
uns angesagt ist.
Wird es auch für die nächsten Jahre sein.
Was hast du denn für einen Kabelverschleiß?
Eigentlich
gar keinen allzu hohen, aber ich wollte halt genug haben.
Äh, SAP.
CFLAIR.
Abonniert Stufe 1.
Big Brain SAP.
Was macht eigentlich der
Q-Chat heute?
Wo gibt es günstige
CAT6A Kabel in allen Längen und Farben?
Mit Sicherheit AliExpress.
Also wenn du da guckst,
Netzwerkkabel kannst du da super kaufen.
Kannst du gleich ein 50er
Pack holen oder so, da hast du auch genug.
Kannst du ja 50 Stück, 1-2 Meter,
iets.
Meistens brauchst du eh die kurzen.
Der Kram kostet nichts.
Kannst du aber auch bei Amazon kaufen.
Die letzten paar habe ich bei Amazon gekauft.
Und das größte Teil,
den größten Teil meiner Kabel habe ich tatsächlich
von der Arbeit, als wir das RZ umgebaut haben.
Ähm, da habe ich
gefragt und da habe ich gesagt, ja, ja,
damit braucht eh kein Mensch mehr.
Und jetzt habe ich hier halt einen Riesenhaufen
an Netzwerkkabeln von 1 Meter bis,
keine Ahnung, 20 Meter oder so.
Muss mal gucken, dass ich keine Subs verpasse.
Äh, nichts verpasst.
Sembaro hat resubscribed.
Eats a la LAN.
Habe ich übersehen, Sembaro.
Ah, die Musik nervt mich gerade.
Hast du Erfahrungen mit Internetleitungen
zu Hause über LTE?
Ne, habe ich nicht, würde ich aber auch nicht machen.
Es sei denn, es geht gar nicht anders.
...
Ja, also das Ding werde ich mir nachher mal
bestellen, weil ich bin ja immer noch scharf
drauf, endlich mal mein
NAS-Build verwirklichen zu können.
Ne, Overwatch spiele ich gerade nicht.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich bräuchte mal eine neue Revision von den Boards
und vielleicht geht mit
dieser Geschichte auch noch was,
dass man noch ein paar Platten mehr dran machen kann,
weil angeblich
alle Gemini Lake Mainboards
SATA-Anschlüsse Port Multiplier
fähig sind.
Also sprich, hier macht man das SATA-Kabel
vom Mainboard dran
und das macht dann aus einem Port halt
fünf.
Was halt auch nicht die Geschwindigkeit steigert,
aber SATA 3
ist schnell genug, dafür mehr als
eine Festplatte.
Wann kommen Slots? Oh, dieses Glücksspielzeug
auf Twitch, das regert mich
irgendwie.
Ich versteh's nicht. Aber jeder wie er will,
ne?
Ja, auf YouTube heute, würde ich sagen,
das Video ist ja echt gut angekommen
und viele Leute, das finde ich immer nice,
viele Leute, die gleichen
beobachten. Übrigens habt ihr's hier gesehen,
Hyper Clickbait Rote Kreise
Thumbnail.
Also man sieht, ich
hab's langsam raus, wie das funktioniert.
Ähm, ist
dieses grüne Lambda-Zeichen
eine Konsole? Ja.
Die hat allerdings seit dem
letzten Upgrade irgendwie ihre Settings vergessen.
Die war mal irgendwie besser
eingestellt. Aber ja, das ist meine Konsole.
Cute Console ist das.
Ja.
Also es ist einfach
3000 mal besser.
Ups, siehste, selbst wenn ich
CMD eingebe, startet der immer noch den Kram.
Warum nicht einfach PowerShell?
Warum, warum?
Schließt sich doch nicht aus.
PowerShell, yeah.
Achso.
Ihhh.
Monkeys, wie geht man aus PowerShell wieder raus?
So. Ähm, das ist ja
kein extra, das ist ja kein extra
Shell. Das ist ja einfach nur
ein ordentliches Terminal, ja. Also was, was
man per Shortcut auf und zu machen kann,
was man ordentlich minimieren kann, wo man Sachen im Hintergrund
laufen lassen kann, was Escape-Sequenzen
unterstützt, was man ordentlich Resizen
kann. Alles das, was man mit dem
normalen Windows-Terminal eben nicht machen kann.
Das ist im Zweifel gehört so einfach
PowerShell
drin laufen lassen.
Was hältst du da von
ChronoBitNet-Webhosting? Weiß ich nicht, kann ja mal gucken.
Was halte ich
davon? Wie hast du das gefunden?
Gucken, was ich davon halte. Muss ich mir mal angucken.
WebBasic.
Oh, sieht doch ganz okay aus.
Die Sache ist
bloß die, kannst du da überhaupt .NET drauf laufen lassen?
Wahrscheinlich eher nicht, oder?
Die werden doch nur PHP haben.
PHP? Ja.
PHP.
Die haben nur PHP, da ist mit
da ist mit .NET Hosting nicht allzu viel.
.NET Hosting ist eigentlich
relativ, relativ teuer, wenn man das managed
haben will. Da fährst du meistens
besser, du mietest dir irgendwas.
Irgendeine VM oder
irgendeinen Server
und machst das dann da drauf.
Ja, wir haben uns sogar das neue Terminal
schon mal angeguckt im Stream.
Das neue Terminal ist
recht nice, hatte noch ein paar Probleme.
Ich kann mich jetzt aber nicht mal daran erinnern, was die Probleme
waren, die wir im Stream gefunden haben.
Ich glaube, ich glaube,
ich glaube,
bestimmte Tasten gingen nicht
ins Terminal durch. Irgendwie sowas.
Ich fandet
ich mal einen VTOL Choke.
Ich fand den, ich fand den
ja massive lul.
Also, wo man immer richtig günstige Sachen
findet.
Aber das ist dann auch, man
bezahlt Low End und man kriegt auch
Low End. Das hier.
Das ist eine coole Seite dafür, weil man
wirklich richtig günstige Sachen haben will.
Nice Toast Brode.
Brode.
Abonniert Stufe 1. Dankeschön.
Pock.
Also die Seite ist
immer ganz praktisch, weil man wirklich Low End
Preise und Low End
haben möchte dafür.
Da kann man sich jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwie
einen
irgendwie Storage oder so raussuchen.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht
mal, wo stand denn hier Storage.
Offers. Storage.
Guck hier, KVM SSD.
KVM 250
im Monat und so Dinger.
Linux. Guck mal.
7 Euro für pro Terabyte.
Und 5,5 Dollar
für ein Terabyte und drauf.
Wobei, das geht noch billiger.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch gesharedes
Storage Hosting.
Also sprich, wo du hinter einem Nut bist
beim Anbieter und keine externe IP mehr hast und so was.
Wenn man das braucht.
Nut Storage Deal.
2 Terabyte für irgendwie
7,50.
Also das lohnt sich mal auf der Seite zu gucken.
Wenn man wirklich billiges Zeugs haben will.
Dementsprechend
ist halt auch die Quali
oftmals.
Also man kann jetzt da nicht super Performance erwarten.
Was ich finde, was der beste Anbieter ist,
wenn man einfach mal
eine 4M
haben will.
Das sind die hier.
Die sind aber nicht super billig.
Aber wenn man einfach online eine
4M braucht, um was auszuprobieren,
finde ich die hier am besten.
Die Dinger haben übelst Wumms.
Die sind ziemlich gut.
Und es ist
super einfach.
Also wenn man wirklich nur mal online eine 4M braucht
zum ausprobieren, sind die eigentlich am besten, finde ich.
Es gibt ähnlich gute.
Aber das ist schon nice.
Kannst halt für 5 Euro
im Monat eine billige 4M.
Nächste Linux 4M.
Und gut ist.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Einfach angelegt, zack, create, Maschine ist da.
Wofür kann man
das dann benutzen? Du hast dann einfach
eine Linux mit einer Public IP.
Da kannst du alles drauf machen, was du willst.
Das sind ganz normale 4Ms.
Du machst den Account, sagst hier create
und dann hast du mit einem
Klick eine 4M.
Mit einem Klick eine 4M.
Wir können uns ja mit GitHub mal einloggen.
Ach fuck, ich bin ja hier nicht eingeloggt.
Okay, können wir nicht.
Oh, da hat einer die Emotes entdeckt.
Da hast du direkt eine 4M und kannst alles
damit machen, was du willst.
Die Musik irgendwie jetzt
aufgedreht oder so.
Egal.
Pock. Benutzt du eigentlich VPN?
Aktuell nicht mehr.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit immer OpenVPN verwendet.
Also eine ganze Zeit lang.
Jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Um mich mit meinem Smartphone...
Oh, das kann ich euch mal zeigen.
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz coole Konstruktion.
Ich habe immer eine Weile
OpenVPN verwendet, dass ich von meinem Smartphone
mich daheim einloggen kann,
um unter anderem auf meine
Heimautomatisierungssache
richtig MLG-Musik,
das Kekseemout, das kommt alles noch.
Ich habe jetzt irgendwie
18 Emote-Slots oder so.
Ja.
Habe ich verwendet, um mich von meinem Smartphone
mobil einloggen zu können.
Und
dann zum Beispiel auf meine
Heimautomatisierung zugreifen zu können und sowas.
Dafür ist OpenVPN
richtig praktisch gewesen.
Die Musik geht mir aber
echt auf den Sack.
So.
Und jetzt mache ich das ganz anders.
Weil ich muss
eigentlich selten wirklich
vom Smartphone auf meine
Heimautomatisierung zugreifen, um irgendwas zu machen.
Ich will aber meinen Standort tracken.
Also ich möchte
tracken, wo
mein, oder sagen wir mal,
wo
Mobilgeräte sind.
Will ich tracken,
weil ich ja
reagieren möchte. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich auf dem Heimweg
bin, dann will ich
wissen, Positionsdaten
von meinem iPhone, will ich
die Positionsdaten wissen, dass
meine Heimautomatisierung checken kann,
okay, ich bin auf dem Weg heim oder von daheim
weg. Und da kann ich dann drauf reagieren.
So. Und das mache ich jetzt
folgendermaßen. Es gibt eine App,
die nennt sich OwnTracks.
Das ist im Prinzip,
ich weiß nicht, was
das kommerzielle Gegenstück ist,
wahrscheinlich Google Maps. Die
Tracking Funktion von Google Maps.
Wahrscheinlich.
Das ist eine App.
Hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
Genau, das ist jetzt auf dem iPhone.
Das ist eine App, da kannst du
verschiedene Server einstellen, an die du
deine Positionsdaten schicken willst.
Und
jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
wie kriege ich die Daten
von meinem Handy mit OwnTrack,
also OwnTrack macht ja nur das Tracking und schickt es an den Server,
jetzt heim zu mir in das Heimautomatisierung
rein. Weil ich habe ja
keine Verbindung von mobil
daheim. So. Und dafür
verwende ich,
das kann ich auch nur empfehlen,
CloudMQTT.
Das ist ein Message Broke,
also so ein Message Queue.
Da kann mein Mobil App,
die OwnTracks App, kann da quasi
die Sachen einfach reinpumpen.
Das läuft online
bei dem Anbieter. Und mein Heimautomatisierungssystem
holt, ruft sich das dann an.
Und so habe ich
immer, ohne dass ich eine aktive Verbindung
von außen nach innen in mein Netzwerk brauche,
habe ich immer die aktuellsten
Positionsdaten von
zwei
Mobilgeräten.
Was wirklich praktisch ist.
Was kostet
eigentlich ein gebrauchtes iPhone 6?
Kosten sowas?
175 Euro!
Ok, die kleinere
Variante
kostet billiger.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Das ist fünf Jahre alt oder so.
Aber das 6er kriege ich echt nicht.
Ich habe da noch ein 6er.
Also jetzt habe ich ein
XR.
Aber ich habe noch ein 6er gerade da.
Oder habe ich ein 6S?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Wo habe ich es überhaupt liegen?
Wo ist es? Warte mal.
Was ist denn das für eins?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Da steht es drauf.
Bei mir steht einfach nur iPhone hinten drauf.
Ja, habe ich.
Äh, Wild Shadow.
Wenn dann S ist,
steht S hinten drauf. Ne.
Ne, steht kein S.
Das ist ein normales iPhone 6.
Heißt das, ein iPhone 6 bekommt kein
iOS 13 mehr? Sehe ich das richtig?
Das wäre aber ganz
schön Sack.
Aber scheiße.
Also ich meine, juckt mich jetzt nicht mehr großartig,
ich habe jetzt ja ein XR.
Aber das ist doof.
Gut, es ist 5 Jahre alt.
Oder 6 Jahre alt.
Und ein 6S?
Was kostet ein 6S?
Ich gucke mal Ebay.
Gib Handy, Alter. Gib Handy.
Ich gucke
bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen.
Ich gucke jetzt bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen und dann schreibe ich
jeden an, was der letzte Preis ist.
iPhone 6S.
So,
was ist der letzte Preis?
Schütze dich vor Betrug.
Hole Artikel persönlich ab. Garantiert.
In Frankfurt gehe ich nicht zu
irgendeinem Dude hin und hole mein Handy ab.
Da wäre ich noch beklaut oder so auf dem Weg.
Jetzt hier.
Was?
Nein, ich melde mich da jetzt nicht an.
Ähm.
Okay, Ebay Kleinanzeigen kaufe ich nichts mehr. Zu blöd.
Aber ein 6S?
Warum sind iPhones so
übertrieben teuer?
Ich meine, man kriegt ein neues?
Was?
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das kleinste iPhone,
das neue Einstiegspreis?
Warum ist die Apple
Webseite schon wieder so hässlich?
Und so
Web 5.0-ig?
Und was ist denn ein guter Mobil-Tarif
aktuell? Also nicht für
mich, ich habe ja mein Zeug schon.
Aber so für Einsteiger.
Do we have
an iPhone for trade-in?
Zählt da mal ein 6er für?
Ich meine,
ich kann mein 6er nicht trade-in,
weil das 6er mir nicht gehört.
Aber ich könnte ja
drauf spekulieren,
dass die vergessen, dass ich noch ein 6er habe
und das 6er trade-in.
Könnte ich Kohle sparen?
Okay, no, habe ich nicht.
Okay, 6,99.
Das ist in Euro wahrscheinlich das gleiche.
Kann man
apple.de nicht?
Wie stelle ich denn die Preise?
Ah, jetzt hier.
Alter, warum kostet
es in Euro
wieder 100 Euro mehr?
Das ist so, das
suckt so, die
Dollar-Euro-Umrechnung. Eigentlich müsstest du
in Euro weniger bezahlen
als in Dollar.
Gut, da kommen noch ein bisschen Taxes und
Geschiss und alles drauf, aber warum kostet es
in Euro schon einfach mal 100 mehr?
Warum kann man
nicht einfach sagen, es kostet das gleiche?
Das würde ich ja noch verstehen.
Feierst du VS Code auch so sehr,
wie ich mag es?
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen,
das ist übertrieben, Feier.
Aber es ist ganz, ganz nett.
Ja, ich
persönlich mag ja Wim immer noch am liebsten.
Leider kann man damit halt
viele Sachen nicht ordentlich machen.
Aber rein von der Bedienung her gefällt
es mir am besten.
Okay, ähm, Farbe.
Product
Red.
Weiß, schwarz will ich es haben.
Ähm,
64G
799.
What the
fuck, Alter.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Das aktuellste iPhone
Einsteigergerät kostet 800 Euro.
Warum zum Teufel
soll ich 200 Euro oder so
ausgeben?
Also ein Viertel vom Preis,
ein, ein
Drittel vom
Preis, nee, ein
Was ist denn das?
2 Fünftel vom Preis.
Ähm,
für ein 5 Jahre
altes Smartphone
3 Achtel vom Preis.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt nicht genauer rechnen, aber
2 Fünftel kommt doch auch ganz gut hin, oder?
Wie viel ist 2 durch 5? 0,4.
Big Brain.
Alte iPhones lohnen nicht, ja.
Alter, was ist mit der Musik los?
Die ist ja mal mega scheiße.
Ja, ich habe auch schon das Wim
das VS Code Plugin verwendet.
Das macht es angenehmer.
Ja, das ist schon besser.
Entspannter.
Äh, oh, ich muss, Leute,
ich muss gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Subs vergessen habe.
Der Sibaro, den hatten
wir schon. Ja, also
irgendwie ganz teuer. So, mal angenommen,
ich würde mir das kaufen, nur mal angenommen.
Theoretisch, ja.
Da ist ja noch nichts dabei.
Was für einen Mobilfunkanbieter
lohnt sich denn aktuell gerade? Oh, huge rate
mit 9 Leuten hier, Poggers. Nice, nice, nice.
Willst du dir ein iPhone bestellen?
Ja, nicht für mich. Ich habe ja schon, also ich habe ja gerade
noch ein 6 und das muss ich
aber wieder zurückgeben und dann jetzt habe ich ein XR.
Sobald ich es mal in Betrieb
nehme. Was für einen Mobilanbieter
ist denn gerade gut?
Was würdet ihr denn so empfehlen?
Was gibt es denn zum Beispiel bei Kongstar gerade?
Ich brauche im Prinzip
eigentlich so gut wie nichts.
Also ist ja nicht für mich, ist ja Einsteiger,
Einsteiger-Handy, Einsteiger.
Gib Handy, Alter.
Tarife.
Weil letztens ist meine Mutter gekommen
und hat gesagt, sie will ihr altes,
die hat noch so ein uraltes
Siemens Club
Handy, so was.
So ein Ding hat die noch, ey.
So was, so was hat die noch.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Dass man so was in 2019
noch verwenden kann.
Alter, Clocks XR.
Fuck.
Das ist halt,
so ein Ding hat die noch.
Und
die wollte jetzt auch ein Smartphone.
Und ich dachte mir erst,
ich frag mal auf der Arbeit,
ob man nicht vielleicht die alten iPhone 6
irgendwie günstig bekommen kann.
Weil da geben jetzt ja gerade hunderte Leute
ihr iPhone 6 ab.
Und da dachte ich mir, tja,
vielleicht. Aber wenn das kein iOS 13
kriegt, ist kacke.
Okay, was gibt es denn hier so schönes?
All Net Flat.
Okay, telefoniert eigentlich so gut wie nie.
5 Gigabit.
Aber 20 Euro im Monat.
Gibt es das nicht irgendwie billiger?
Was ist denn eine Fairflat?
Was? Fairflat?
2 Gigabyte.
Und wie viel, wie viel?
Hä?
Was würdet ihr denn empfehlen?
Ich habe wirklich keinen blassen Schimmer
von Mobilanbietern.
Was würdet ihr denn für Mobilanbieter empfehlen?
Was? SimpliTel?
Aldi Talk?
Check24 Vergleich?
Okay.
Smartphone Tarif
Vergleich.
Gucken wir mal.
Check24 Handy Tarife.
Penny.
Erstmal zu Penny.
Handy gewünscht? Nein.
Datenvolumen.
Aber ab 1G.
Tarife für junge Leute.
Nur bis zum Alter von 28.
Oh ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Vertragslaufzeit.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich keinen Bock auf 24 Monate.
Aber
schauen wir mal.
Inklusive Minutentelefon.
Eigentlich ist es egal.
Telefoniert so gut wie nie.
Wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mit dem Handy.
Jule berät uns.
Sie fragen sich welcher Tarif zu ihnen passt.
Gemeinsam finden wir das beste Angebot.
Ja Jule, dann
schieß los.
Thorsten auch.
Haben sie Fragen.
Sie erreichen uns innerhalb einer Minute.
Steve.
Oh Steve hat keine gute Bewertung.
Samira.
Samira hat gute Bewertung.
Ich weiß zwar nicht warum ich da anrufen sollte.
Dielek.
Da ist Jule wieder.
Okay.
Ich glaube wir kriegen das auch ohne die hin.
LTE Smart 100.
Ich finde die Seite total unübersichtlich.
Oder geht es bloß mir so?
Okay, was habt ihr eben gesagt?
Aldi Talk.
Wenn ich so Fotos
schon sehe.
Kombipakete.
Prepaid.
Oh Prepaid das finden die bestimmt toll.
Aber Prepaid lohnt sich halt wahrscheinlich null.
Vor allem wozu sollte man Prepaid machen?
Wozu?
Prepaid und trotzdem
12€ im Monat bezahlen ist halt
next level big brain.
7,99€ pro 4 Wochen.
Was hat das mit Prepaid zu tun?
Freenet Funk.
Freenet Funk, sowas gibt es?
Wusste gar nicht das Freenet
soll das sein.
Ist doch hier eine App oder?
Aha.
Was es alles gibt.
Du kaufst es mit Guthaben und nach 4 Wochen hört es auf.
Und du kaufst es neu.
Ja gut, aber dann verfällt ja mein Guthaben
wenn ich es in der Zwischenzeit nicht gebraucht habe.
Freenet Funk ist eigentlich ganz anders.
Ich speichere mir das mal.
Guck jetzt erstmal Aldi Talk. Was haben die denn da?
Tarifdetails.
Kombipakete. Paket S.
7,99€. Das ist top.
Einmalig.
7,99€?
Das ist doch gut.
Das ist doch eigentlich ganz nice oder?
8€ im Monat.
2G.
Das reicht der.
Und so viele Gespräche.
Was haben die?
Was Freenet Funk ist? Ich guck mir das gleich mal an.
Das reicht auch.
Ist halt okay.
Sagt O2NETS.
Okay.
Ja. Geht so.
Warum sagt O2NETS?
Wir sind ja in der Stadt.
Wir sind ja hier in der Stadt.
Ja, die ist ja nur
hier in der Stadt unterwegs.
Da denke ich nicht, dass es da Probleme gibt.
Okay, wie kann man das kündigen?
Kündigungsfrist, ist das auch einmal im Monat?
Kündigungsfrist 0.
Okay.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde diese...
Also das Aldi Flat-Ding sieht gar nicht so doof aus.
Ich meine, guck mal hier.
2G-Datenvolumen reicht ihr locker aus.
Flatrate, gut SMS.
Wer schreibt SMS? Kein Mensch schreibt mehr SMS.
Das heißt...
Boah, da muss ich...
Ich will kein neues iPhone kaufen.
Aber die brauchen ein iPhone.
Die brauchen unbedingt ein iPhone, weil...
Wir haben hier jetzt bei
daheim massig Android-Geräte,
aber wo sie mit Abstand am besten
klarkommt, obwohl wir wieder beim Thema sind,
dass Noobs tatsächlich ganz gut
mit Apple klarkommen, man kann ja mit Apple
oftmals wenig machen an vielen Stellen,
also vor allem was Automatisierung
angeht,
dass sie am besten damit klarkommen.
Das heißt, die brauchen ein iPhone.
Was kostet ein iPhone 8?
Was ist denn das letzte iPhone mit Homebutton?
Alter, 400 Euro!
Fuck!
Warum ist das so teuer?
Ich raffe das mit dem bedienerfreundlichen...
Ich auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber ich sehe halt, dass es so ist.
Okay, 16G
reicht.
Noch teurer.
Apple SE?
Was ist denn iPhone SE?
Was ist denn
Apple SE?
6S?
Aha.
Ja, das ist doch gut, das ist schon günstig.
Senior.
Ist das immer noch aktuell?
Ne? Ein 6er ist gut genug.
Ne, ein 6er kriegt kein iOS 13.
Also ich brauche
auf jeden Fall, die muss auf jeden Fall
iOS 13 kriegen auf ihr Handy.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich kann euch auch sagen warum.
Weil mit iOS 13
gibt es Background Tasks.
Und Background Tasks
brauche ich,
um beispielsweise die Türklingel
und die Kamera an der Außenwand,
wenn eine klingelt,
ordentlich bedienbar
zu machen auf dem Handy.
Weil du kannst,
ich habe es dir schon öfters erzählt,
du kannst halt unter iOS nichts gescheit
automatisieren.
Und jetzt mit iOS 13
geht es halt zum ersten Mal,
dass du im Hintergrund
iPhone
Dinge abrufen lassen kannst.
8er geholt, ja.
Also 8er gibt es nur
A64G.
Ist aber ganz,
ist trotzdem ganz schön teuer.
Ich meine, muss ich das mal reinziehen, ne?
Das ist das vorvorvorletzte
oder so, oder vorvorletzte ist das?
Vorvorvorletzte, ne?
iPhone 8, so.
Und es kostet immer noch
die Hälfte
von einem neuen.
Super, 2020, Dankeschön.
6S oder SE würde
dicke reichen, denke ich auch.
Ist das,
aber das SE, das SE
muss doch noch aktuell sein,
weil
es gibt doch nichts Vergleichbares
von Apple aktuell, oder?
Ja, iPhone.
Ne, ne,
Android hole ich nicht
für die.
Außerdem ist das Schöne bei Apple Geräten,
da kann sie mir wenigstens ein Message schreiben.
Okay, das SE ist anscheinend
vergleichen.
SE.
Man kann das SE noch nicht mal offiziell kaufen.
Ja, was ist denn,
was ist denn von Apple,
was ist denn von Apple aktuell
die,
die Low-Budget-Variante?
Hast du nicht ein gutes Ding?
Doch, doch, ich habe ein iPhone XR,
aber ich suche für meine Mutter was.
Was, 10R? XR?
Ich habe, das heißt,
mein Budget, mein Budget-Handy
kostet 700 Euro.
Das ist doch keine Alternative zu einem Handy, was 150
kostet.
Fuck.
Das ist doch, ist das Apple-Logik, oder?
8er kaufen,
ja, ich glaube auch.
6S kannst du nicht mal kaufen.
7er kannst du auch noch mal kaufen, hier.
8er.
Ne, 7er gibt es nicht, aber
wir können mal gucken, hier.
250.
Gibt es das mit 16G?
Ne, gibt es nicht.
32G.
250?
Okay.
Ich meine,
ich meine ganz ehrlich,
das andere kostet 800,
also das sind 200, 270 Euro Unterschied.
Und es hat einen Home-Button.
Dass es einen Home-Button hat,
finde ich wichtig,
weil es ist halt Bedienung gewohnt vom iPad.
Das iPad hat einen Home-Button.
Naja, gut, war es auch immer.
Also, ich rechne jetzt mal so grob über den Daumen
über den Daumen gepeilt,
wäre ich wahrscheinlich
ungefähr 600 Euro ausgeben müssen
für das iPhone
und
irgendwie 8 Euro im Monat
für einen
halbwegs gescheiten Tarif.
Ja, ich meine, es geht doch.
Es geht doch. Dafür, dass er dann nicht mal
mit ihrem komischen Siemens-Handy da rumhantieren muss,
ist es doch nicht verkehrt.
Das 6X kriegt,
kriegst du noch neu
für 299, aber nicht mal bei Apple,
sondern muss ich mal gucken bei irgendeinem
bei irgendeinem Shop.
Dann ein 6S würde ich mir auch,
wäre auch okay, würde auch dicke reichen.
Ich meine, Hauptsache, Hauptsache,
Hauptsache er ist 13.
Du hast ja das YouTube-Money.
Nee, ich habe das Twitch-Subscriber-Money.
Ich mache das jetzt wie
Dings hier, Korean Savage.
Mache einfach ein Spenden-Video.
Ja.
Dass wir unbedingt ein neues iPhone
brauchen, weil sonst ganz, ganz
passiert ganz, ganz, ganz schlimme Dinger.
Und wenn dann, wenn ich dann das Geld
eingesammelt habe, dann mache ich dann
ein Video, mein neuer Lifestyle vom
Strand oder so.
Mein, mein neues Gaming-Zimmer
mache ich dann.
Und dann sage ich dabei,
ja, Moment, Leute, das hat nichts mit dem Geld zu tun,
was ihr gespendet habt.
Das Geld mit dem, was ihr gespendet habt, ist natürlich
da überhaupt nicht reingeflossen.
Das Timing war einfach echt blöde bei dem.
Zeig mal den Vertrag für Internet.
Das Ding hier, Aldi, Aldi Talk
war das hier. Guck, das da.
Das da haben wir gerade entdeckt.
Dennoch, 300 Euro für
ein vier Jahre altes Teil, echt brutal. Ja, finde ich
auch. Ich meine, für, für
300 Euro kriegst du ein relativ gutes
Android-Smartphone. Neu.
Jetzt natürlich jetzt irgendwie kein,
was sind da angesagt, Galaxy,
Dingsbums oder
OnePlus, noch was Neues.
Aber was halbwegs Gescheites, ja.
Neues.
Das Schöne an Android ist halt, dass man so viel
automatisch machen kann, was unter Apple
nicht geht. Und deswegen, deswegen will ich
auch unbedingt iOS 13 haben.
Ich habe mir das eben schon
überlegt, ne,
es heißt nicht mehr Workflow, oder? Wie heißt denn das jetzt?
Shortcuts, oder?
Shortcuts iOS
13.
Die haben jetzt Background
Tasks. Und ich werde das so
machen, du kannst, du kannst das nur
einmal alle Minute anwerfen, diese Background
Tasks.
Thomas Kuhl, 110, Poggas
Subscriber. Kennst du
IFTTTT? Ja, kenn ich.
Mag ich aber net so.
Weil es ein ziemlich großes Delay hat.
Wenn man was bra...
Wenn man was haben möchte, was
einfach nur was tut, ab und zu mal, ist das
okay, wenn man was hat, was wirklich auch zeitnah reagieren
soll, ist es doof.
Beispielsweise meine Haustürklingel über
IFTTTT. Was ein Name, kann keiner aussprechen.
IFTTTT.
Machen würde halt, hätte übelst lag
und würde nicht funktionieren.
Konfigurier das mal auf Maximum.
Das kostet wahrscheinlich 1600 Euro, oder so.
Nein?
Max?
Nachtgrün?
Ja, wenn schon, brauche ich so die hässliche neue Farbe.
Ih, das ist ja,
das ist ja fast geschenkt, ja.
Fast
geschenkt. Ich meine, ich habe eh
Tim Cook über dem Bett hängen.
Da kann man schon mal in die Kasse greifen,
ja. Woher kommt dieses
bei? So, das ist ein koreanisches
Text-to-Speech-Software.
Konfigurier mal
den 5K iMac.
Wollen wir das mal machen?
Eigentlich wollte ich noch was einkaufen heute, aber...
iMac Pro. Ne, was für einen iMac soll ich
konfigurieren?
Den da. Okay.
Ist das der mit dieser komischen Tastatur?
Ja, das ist der.
Diese Tastatur, es ist
schrecklich. Okay.
Bye. Den anderen
...
Ist der nicht teuer genug, oder was?
Ist der nicht...
Kostet der nicht genug?
Ist der nicht teuer genug?
Sag mal.
Nicht das richtig?
Ich soll für eine fucking Vega 48?
Heißt die überhaupt 48?
Das ist so ein
special Ding, oder?
Das ist irgend so ein special
zertifiziertes Sonstwas-Ding, was kein Mensch
braucht, ja. Guck mal.
Die normale kostet einfach nur 177 Euro.
Das ist doch nicht...
Das ist doch nicht in den Ernst, oder?
5800 Euro.
Ich mein, 2 TB SSD
hab ich jetzt auch.
Hab ich schon seit ein paar Jahren drin.
1008 Ti ist drinne.
Okay, ich geb zu, ich hab nur 32G.
Oder ich glaub, ich hab sogar nur...
Warum kostet der RAM denn bitteschön so viel?
Warum kostet denn
der RAM so viel?
RAM ist zur Zeit
absolut
billig.
Der RAM kostet nix normalerweise.
Der ist verlötet, ey. Klar,
dass du nicht umtauschen, dass du nicht selbst was reinmachen
kannst. Äh, warte mal ab.
RAM kostet grad gar nix, ey.
Moment hier. Nee, also gar nix.
Wenig, ja. Okay, wir machen
das mal. Speicher. Was ist da drinne?
Wir gucken uns gleich den anderen iMac an, ja.
Ey, iMac Pro. Also,
warte mal hier.
266.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie Hyperspeed, irgendwie so wäre, oder so.
Kann man nicht sagen
genau Takt 266?
Ja. So, 64.
Apple.
Was ist da los?
Habt ihr einfach mal ne 0
dran gehängt, oder was?
Warum soll ich für Apple RAM
1000, also zusätzlich
1200 Euro
bezahlen, wohingegen
64G RAM aktuell 250 Euro
kosten, oder? Okay, sagen wir mal,
gehen wir hier irgendwie runter.
Hier, kostet ein bisschen mehr.
Und das ist ein Einzelmodul.
Moment, das ist Einzelmodul.
Das stimmt ja noch nicht mal. Wir müssen
Kit, Kit müssen wir gucken.
Packungsgröße, was ist denn
Packungsgröße?
Kit-Größe.
Ja, guck mal.
4 RAM-Riegel, wahrscheinlich sind da auch
4 RAM-Riegel drinne.
250 Euro.
50 Euro.
Ist das so teuer?
Fuck, Alter, ist das teuer.
Das ist, das ist huge teuer.
Das ist einfach
10 mal mehr.
Gut, okay.
iMac Pro.
Das war noch nicht teuer genug, Leute.
Da geht noch was.
Okay, da geht schon mal
ab 5500 Euro los.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt sind wir im Klartext hier.
Das ist so teuer,
da können sich MontanaBlack
und das rechte Auge noch den Apple,
den Apfel tätowieren lassen.
Passend zur Rolex-Krone.
Sollen wir mal irgendwelche Deals machen.
So teuer,
dafür kriegst du auch ne Rolex.
Okay.
18-Core
Intel Xeon. Okay, das braucht kein Mensch.
Wir, wir, wir sind mal,
wir sind mal realistisch.
Ein 8-Kern-Xeon 3,2 Gigahertz
ist absolut ausreichend
und ist wahrscheinlich für das meiste
sogar praktischer als
Achso, der boostet
teuer, okay.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
Alter.
Ho, ho, ho.
Apple,
haben die den vergoldeten, vergoldeten
RAM oder was?
Nehmen die den 10-Core. Ey, der CPU-Preis
macht überhaupt nichts aus im Vergleich
zum RAM.
Alter.
6000 für, für
RAM.
Okay, Moment.
Wir machen das, wir machen das jetzt nochmal.
Ähm, Kitgrö...
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Kitgröße und
Packungsgröße?
Okay, ECC.
Äh.
Oh Gott.
Mit ECC, bebuffert
und buffert.
ECC.
Ja gut, dann nehmen wir halt ein Kit.
So, okay.
Also.
Wir nehmen einfach zwei Stück davon.
Das ist schon teuer.
Das ist schon ganz schön teuer.
Ähm, wir nehmen mal
Einzelmodul.
Wir nehmen mal 64G.
Ja, easy.
Easy.
Einfach vier Stück, vier Stück
davon rein und gut ist.
Da werden auch nicht nur zwei Sachen,
da werden auch vier RAM-Module drin sein.
Okay, also wir geben ungefähr 1000 Euro
aus.
Das kostet 1000 Euro.
Bei Apple kostet das
6000 Euro.
Für wahrscheinlich ziemlich genau den
gleichen RAM.
Okay, bam.
Also von wegen, ein Rolex geht ab 10.000 los.
iMac lacht sich kaputt über 10.000 Euro.
So, wir brauchen jetzt natürlich noch
eine Grafikkarte, eine ordentliche.
Wobei, die reicht eigentlich.
Aber 2TB SSD sollte es
eigentlich schon sein.
Ah ja.
Das verstehe ich, das verstehe ich.
Also ich denke,
bei einem
Rechner für 13.000
Euro,
da sollte, da sollte
keine Halterung dabei sein.
Also das ist ja quasi schon
komplett
am unteren Limit.
Da kann man schon mal 85 Euro nochmal für die
Halterung verlangen.
Boah.
Und ey, der Witz ist halt, wenn ich mir das
kaufe, also ich kaufe es mir nicht, ne.
Ich sag nur.
Abkalkuliert, ja.
Also wenn ich mir das kaufen würde,
ich hätte keine Ahnung, was ich denn machen soll.
Das Video von Snazzy Labs
zu dem VESA Kit gesehen. Ne, hast du einen Link?
Kann man sich mal angucken, jetzt wo wir gerade schon beim
leichten Apple-Bashen sind.
Aber das ist schon
krass. Ich meine, okay,
was kriegt man im Endeffekt?
Einen 10-Kern,
einen 10-Kern-CPU?
Das kannst du wahrscheinlich mit dem aktuellen Ryzen besser haben.
Weiß gar nicht was.
Also 8-Kern Ryzen sind ja nicht so das Ding.
Es gibt, ich glaube es gibt keine 10-Kern,
es gibt nur 12-Kern, ne.
Äh.
Wo ist denn deine
Übersicht? Wo ist denn deine Übersicht?
Nicht Overview, wo ist denn deine
Übersicht, was es alles für
Ryzen 3 CPUs gibt?
Wiki-Chip?
Alles gibt.
Ja.
Ach, Moment, ich muss nach
Ryzen 3, ich muss
nach Zen 2
oder so suchen, ne.
Na, was muss ich denn da suchen, dass ich eine ordentliche Übersicht
finde, äh,
wie die neueste Ryzen-CPU ist.
Ja. So.
Kerne.
Den brauchen wir.
Ryzen 9 3900X.
12 Kerne.
Ja, so.
Das ist das passende Ding.
Also wir könnten uns wahrscheinlich, also rein mal von
der Hardware, ja. Wenn wir uns einen Rechner
zusammenbauen wollen, der sogar noch
eine ganze Ecke leistungsfähiger ist,
dieses Ding hier. Gut, eins muss man
denen zugute halten,
ähm, die Displays sollen wohl,
ich kann das nicht aus erster Hand, äh,
berichten, ja.
Die Displays sollen wohl ziemlich gut
sein und auch standardmäßig ordentlich kalibriert,
aber für den Preis
kannst du dir irgendwie einen ordentlichen,
ich sag mal irgendwie, ISO ist beispielsweise
ganz gut bei irgendwelchen
Bildschirmen, die halt auch
korrekt sein müssen, ja.
Ähm, oder was gibt's noch lieber?
Also, äh, da kann ich mir einfach noch
einen viel besseren Monitor
dabei kaufen oder einen ähnlich guten Monitor
dabei kaufen. Wobei die schon
wirklich gut sein sollen. So, ähm,
also ich mein,
wenn, wir geben wahrscheinlich,
sagen wir mal so, wir geben 3000 Euro
aus, 3000 Euro
und da haben wir
auch 256G
RAM drinne,
ne 2080 Ti,
nen Ryzen
3000 Euro nix
und dann kommen wir mit 3000 Euro
locker hin. Krass.
Das ist echt heftig, also das ist nicht ohne.
So, was haben wir denn jetzt hier für ein Video?
Apple, was ist das?
Apple Store Genius Bar Broke.
Okay.
Was ist das für ein Benchmark?
Was ist das für ein Benchmark, weiß das jemand?
Ist kein Battlefield.
GTA, ah, GTA.
Man kann da RAM selbst
reinmachen? Okay.
Das geht beim aktuellen bestimmt nicht mehr.
Ich habe noch einen Anzug,
und ich muss noch mal
den Anzug anpassen.
So,
also,
es ist ein
ja,
Back in January I installed the mount for the first time, and it went just fine.
It comes with a little credit card-sized tool that allows you to reveal the nine screws
that hold the iMac onto the stand.
And once you remove all of those screws, the stand comes off very easily, and then
you can put the VESA mount on.
Which surprisingly only uses five of the nine available screw holes, but I thought, you
know, whatever, Apple's great at design, I'm sure it's not an issue.
Well, fast forward to March, I'm filming a video and I want to take the iMac off of
the VESA kit and put it back on the stand.
Now look, I'm sure it's not designed to be pulled on and off and on and off over and
over and over, but it never says that you shouldn't take it off or that you can take
it off.
So I did.
And in the process, when I was backing out one of the five screws, which was not over-tightened
by the way, the screw head just broke clean off from the screw body and it left the screw
stuck inside of the screw hole threads.
The end result?
Well, this.
I couldn't remove the VESA.
Fuck.
Du kommst ja von, du kommst ja von unten wahrscheinlich nicht dran, ne?
Kommst wahrscheinlich nicht richtig dran von unten.
Wie würde man sowas jetzt rauskriegen?
Da, da ist big, da ist big brain time angesagt.
Ich würde versuchen, was anzulöten vielleicht.
Vielleicht könnte man, vielleicht könnte man da was dran löten.
Ne, die Schraube steckt ja da noch drinne.
Die Schraube steckt ja noch drinne.
Vielleicht kann man einfach.
Einfach Metall, einfach noch, einfach noch ein Stück Metall oben anlöten an die Schraube
oder kleben, keine Ahnung, was auch immer und dann rausdrehen.
Verkaufen.
Beste Idee, mit einem klapprigen VESA mal das Ding verkaufen.
Mit einem kleinen Bohrer reinbohren.
Ja, vielleicht, ja.
Also ich würde es wahrscheinlich versuchen, irgendwie was dran zu löten.
Einfach Metall oben und es dann rausziehen mit.
Oder rausdrehen mit.
Ich meine, man könnte auch irgendeinen besonders starken Kleber verwenden oder so.
Ne, rausziehen mit einem Magnet kannst du nicht.
Das ist ja ein Gewinde, das musst du drehen.
Also müsstest du es quasi mit dem Magnet drehen.
Und das, der Magnet müsste doch schon verdammt stark sein, dass die Schraube so fest an dem
Magnet ist über diese Sache hier, dass du ihn damit abdrehen kannst.
Das kannst du vergessen.
Also ich denke mal, der hat es schon rausgekriegt.
Ich glaube, der hat es schon rausgekriegt.
Der hat es schon rausgekriegt.
Was er sagt, der hat es schon rausgekriegt.
Naja, in Ordnung.
Ich glaube, der hat es schon rausgekriegt.
Ne?
Ja, aber das ist doch für denjenigen, der das kauft, scheißegal.
Also ich glaube, in Deutschland wäre das so ohne weiteres gar nicht möglich.
Apple verkauft, also sag mal so, wenn, keine Ahnung, wenn jetzt Amazon, keine Ahnung, einen Alienware-PC verkauft und das Ding hat irgendwelche Mängel und spackt rum,
dann kannst du dich an Alienware wenden, wenn du nett bist, aber du musst nicht.
Da ist eigentlich immer der Händler verpflichtet, von dem du es gekauft hast, jetzt nicht Support zu leisten, aber wenn das Ding Mängel hat, die zu beheben.
Ich meine, wenn du nett bist, gehst du zu Alienware, aber musst du nicht.
In Deutschland, ja, genau.
Also ich habe gerade irgendwas runtergeschmissen und ich finde es nicht mehr.
Übelst MonkaS.
Das war hier vor meinem Essen, war noch übrig geblieben, das habe ich jetzt irgendwo runtergeschmissen und will nicht, dass es unter meinem Schreibtisch liegt.
Also erstens frisst es dann wahrscheinlich die Katz, das wäre nicht das Schlimmste.
Zweitens, wenn es irgendwo drunter liegt, dann fängt es irgendwann an zu schimmeln oder so.
Mal nachher suchen, wo das hingefallen ist.
Egal, machen wir weiter.
Aber ich bin nicht so weit gekommen, weil der erste Schraubendreher gut ging, aber der zweite Schraubendreher, als ich ihn schraube, hast du es verpasst, brach das Schraubendreher, genau wie der erste.
Jetzt erinnere dich, dass dies nur die zweite Zeit ist, dass ich dieses Ding aufnehme und ich war super vorsichtig, dass ich die Schrauben nur so wenig schraube, dass ich gesehen habe, wie einfach der erste brach.
Es ist nur so, dass Apple die grössten Zink-Schrauben jemals auf dieser 90-Dollar-Kette für ihre 5.000-Dollar-Plus-Maschine inkludiert.
Es ist absurd.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie nicht Stahl-Schrauben inkludieren, die so viel mehr kosten und viel mehr langweilig sind.
Offensichtlich habe ich ein Problem.
Ich kann keinen 25-Pound-Computer mit drei dinkigen kleinen Schrauben montieren.
Also habe ich einen Apple-Diskussions-Forum-Thread auf apple.com gefunden, mit ein paar anderen Usern, die auch Erfahrungen mit Apple-Schrauben haben.
Ich dachte, Apple hat sicherlich eine Lösung gefunden in den letzten 30 Tagen, weil andere Menschen das Problem haben.
Es wird alles gut sein.
Nein.
Nicht nur das, aber auch der Telefon-Repräsentant hat mir gesagt, dass ich einfach in die Genius-Gruppe gehe.
In die Genius-Bar an einem Apple-Store.
Weil er nicht mal Training oder sogar Zugang zu der Support-Dokumentation für iMac Pro hatte.
Dass der einzige Weg, um Support für iMac Pro zu erhalten, war, an einen Apple-Store zu gehen.
Es ist mir flabbergastig, dass niemand auf dem Telefon an Apple kann die Kunden unterstützen, die ihm 1.000 und 1.000 Dollar für einen Computer geben.
Aber, egal.
Ich hätte auch eigene Schrauben dafür gesucht.
Ungefährlich, wie die meisten iMac-Pro-Bauern, lebe ich nahe an einigen Apple-Storen.
Also habe ich mir gedacht, es ist nicht so ein großes Problem.
Ich bin in einen der Store gegangen.
Und es war eine Brise.
Und alles wurde in einem Gipfel geschlossen.
Richtig?
Nein.
Also bin ich in den Apple-Store 5 Minuten früh gekommen und musste fast eine Stunde warten für den Head-Genius.
Das war ein Begriff, den ich noch nie gehört habe, übrigens.
Weil er der Einzige ist, der in dem Store trainiert ist, um zu arbeiten.
Sieht so in einem Apple-Store aus?
Ich war in meinem Leben noch nie in einem Apple-Store.
Das sieht für mich aus wie irgendwie so ein Hipster-Café oder so.
Ist das ein Apple-Store?
Das sieht aus wie so ein Hipster-Café, wo alle Salat- und Veggie-Burnen...
Und die grünen Typen, sind das Apple-Leute?
Mit dem Grün?
Weil da sind so viele in grün.
Sind das die Apple-Dudes?
Warum sind die grün?
Warum sind die nicht leuchtend weiß oder so?
Also ich finde, das sieht übelst aus wie irgendein Hipster-Ding, wo jeder Veggie-Burger und Salat futtert.
Plus das alle.
Man muss dazu sagen, wahrscheinlich liegt es da dran, wenn du bei uns um die Ecke, wo ich arbeite, in einen dieser Läden reingehst.
Das Erste, was du da...
...siehst, sind halt die Typen mit ihrem Macbook oder mal zumindest einem iPad und zumindest Airpods.
Deswegen sieht es wahrscheinlich so ähnlich aus.
Okay, weiter.
...on iMac Pro, a computer that has been out for nearly six months.
Now, to give my Apple-Store credit, once I did finally meet with the genius, he was very understanding of the situation.
And he told me that even though their system said it was considered accidental damage, was not covered by warranty,
and would incur an $80 minimum repair fee, that he saw it as a clear design flaw and that the store would do the repair for free in three to five days.
Great.
Not the most elegant repair experience ever, but we're finally making progress.
Three to five days?
I can handle that.
Well, seven days pass, and I've heard nothing.
So I call the store and I ask them what's up.
The guy on the phone tells me that they had already attempted the repair, but, quote, failed to perform it correctly, end quote.
Whatever that means.
So additional parts and tools that were needed for the repair...
The repair had been ordered, but they had no ETA on when those parts would arrive or when the repair would be finished.
Hä?
All right.
Well, not five minutes after hanging up the phone, I get a call from the store manager, who tells me a completely different story.
That the repair is going fine, that the parts have already arrived...
Good, it's the manager.
...and that the genius who started my repair isn't working over the weekend, but that they've prioritized the repair,
the other geniuses know what to do, and it will be done by Monday.
Finally.
On Monday morning, I get a call telling me that they need the iMac stand,
that I had here at the office, and I told them that they could put it on the stand if they needed to,
but I would prefer them to just install it on the base amount, it'd be easier for me, easier for them, whatever.
And they said that they would, but they need the stand to finish the repair.
Hä?
Okay.
So, Monday afternoon, I drop the stand off at the Apple store, and they told me that it would probably be done by Monday evening.
Ich hätte die erst mal genervt, was sie damit machen wollen.
Tuesday passes, nothing.
I call Wednesday morning, day 13 of this three-to-five-day repair,
and I'm told the following, quote,
this iMac Pro is new, and some of the geniuses were confused.
They didn't know that the base amount was removable,
but our head genius is back today, says he knows how to fix it,
and hopefully it'll be done by Monday.
Scheinen ja wahnsinnige Big Brains zu sein bei Apple, ja.
Okay, first of all, the base amount is the whole entire repair.
Secondly, how can a genius not know that that's removable?
Trained on the iMac Pro or not,
that's literally something that's stalled,
in the store, I mean, they should know that.
But, whatever.
Wednesday night at 9pm,
I'm delighted to see an email that says the repair is complete,
and I'm ready for pickup the next morning.
Jetzt ist er kaputt.
Ich wette, jetzt ist er kaputt.
No, it's not.
I went into the Apple store Wednesday morning,
picked up my computer,
and as I'm getting in my car,
Ach du Scheiße.
I noticed that the stand that they requested on Monday
was completely chowdered.
The fuck?
Wie schafft man das denn?
Die Aluminium-Ankerpunkte waren so verschwunden,
dass ich nicht wusste, ob ich den Stand noch auf dem iMac zurückziehen kann.
Also ging ich zurück in den Store,
sagte, hey, was ist los?
Und hier ist ein gedrehter Schnitt des Events.
Wir können definitiv in die News bestellen.
Wir hatten Dokumente, wir hatten Dokumente von den Schrecken,
aber nicht dieses.
Das waren keine Schrecken, das war brandneu.
Oh, wirklich?
Es ist, ich meine, es ist in Ordnung.
Ich kümmere mich nicht um die Schrecken.
Kosmetisch, aber wenn ich es nicht aufbauen kann, ist das ein Problem.
Wir werden einen neuen haben.
Oh, danke, dass ich das verstanden habe.
Um.
Okay.
Wir hatten einen neuen Stand.
Aber jetzt bin ich ein bisschen interessiert,
ob der Stand so verschwunden war.
Ist mein iMac unter dem Vase-Mantel beschädigt?
Also schauen wir uns das mal an.
Okay, also, wir entfernen den iMac von diesem Schutzschlauch.
Was haben die gemacht?
Ja, das ist gut.
Sie haben das Glas nicht zerstört,
also sind wir auf einem guten Start.
Okay, jetzt brauche ich einen Torx-TR10-Schraubendreher.
Brich erstmal die Schraube wieder ab wahrscheinlich.
Gut, das ist nicht sehr fest.
Also habe ich hohe Hoffnungen, dass der Genius nicht, naja, das ist okay.
Sagen die wirklich, sagen die allen Ernstes zu ihren Mitarbeitern, Genius?
Ist mir egal, ob das Apple-Leute sind oder nicht.
Ich würde, ich würde niemanden pauschal als Genius bezeichnen.
Das ist Big, Big Brain.
Genius Bar.
Okay, man merkt, ich habe eine riesen Bildungslücke.
Weil ich noch nie in einem Apple-Store gewesen bin.
Aber alles, was ich bisher davon erfahre,
sorgt eher dafür, dass ich auch weiterhin nicht in einen Apple-Store rein möchte.
Okay, one screw comes out okay.
Two screws come out okay.
Was für ein Bullshit, ey.
And now we get to the trouble part.
Okay, so hopefully the Genius didn't over-tighten these.
Jetzt bricht's ab, jetzt bricht's ab.
Very gently.
And wow, yeah, no, he was, he was nervous.
These are barely finger-tight even.
Sind gar nicht richtig drin.
Look at that.
So he was, he was even spooked.
Seht ihr, seht ihr, wie kaputt der Scheiß schon ist?
Ich meine, es kann doch nicht sein, dass beim puren rein- und rausschrauben schon Splitter vom Gehäuse abgehen.
He was even spooked.
Just careful not to over-tighten, which was good.
Okay, we've got two out successfully.
No way.
Abgebrochen?
Are you kidding me?
Nee, den war gar nicht fest, hä?
Look at that.
That's broken clean off.
Ha!
Look.
Oh, Gott, ey.
That's broken.
I don't, I'm not gonna be able to get this thing off again.
This is the worst designed Apple product I've ever, ever laid my hands on.
Okay, that one came out fine.
Here comes the last one.
Let's hope it doesn't break, too.
All right, that came out okay.
Das ist doch lächerlich, ey.
You've gotta be kidding me.
This is a joke.
I mean, I guess at least it broke to the point where I can pull it off.
But look at that.
That's one of the screws broken.
We're already back to square one.
Okay, it's not messed up as badly as the stand, but almost.
Got a nick there, nick there, nick there.
Alter, das ist voll im Arsch, ey.
Was machen die denn damit?
The whole bottom row is like shaved off.
You've gotta be kidding me.
So, we're back to square one.
It's broken again.
I'm probably just gonna leave it on the base I'm out.
Jetzt ist der Punkt erreicht, wo du eigentlich die weiter nerven müsstest, allerdings
die meisten Leute, und ich zähle mich jetzt mal auch dazu, wenn ich nicht gerade besonders
Bock drauf habe, Leute zu ärgern oder mich zu ärgern oder sonst was, jetzt ist der Punkt
erreicht, wo ich normalerweise sagen würde, scheiß drauf.
Und das ist eigentlich verkehrt, weil eigentlich müsstest du die abfacken bis zum Schluss,
bis der Scheiß funktioniert.
Aber da hat man meistens keinen Bock drauf.
Aber wie kann Apple z.B. einen $88-Adapter für einen $5000-bettlosen Computer verkaufen, mit
Schrecken, die sich jedes mal wieder trennen lassen?
Es war nicht nur mein Adapter, der schlechte Schlüsse hatte.
Das ist ein brandneues, das Apple drei Tage heruntergekauft hat, in der Apple Store.
Schon gebrochen.
Das sind Bananen.
Nicht nur bin ich überrascht, aber ich bin einfach so überzeugt vom ungeschichten
Begrüßung derjenigen von den Telefon-Mehrheiten und den Geniusen in der Apple-Store, bei denen
Apple mit benefited.
Es geht ja alles um die Software.
Es gibt auch dieяти.
Naja, mich macht es fertig, dass die Genius heißen.
Das hätte Peter besser gekonnt, ey.
Peter vom indischen Microsoft-Support hätte das besser gekonnt.
Meine Fiverr-Programmierer hätten das besser gekonnt.
Das hätte jeder besser gekonnt.
Apple hat historisch über und über
um ihre Pro-User glücklich zu machen.
Als meine Mac-Pro-GPUs aus der Warrantie verbrannt wurden,
haben sie sie verwendet.
Als ich meine Trash-Can-Mac-Pro hatte,
habe ich immer, wenn ich für Unterstützung ruft,
sofort zu einem hohen-Tier-Advisor gekommen.
Kein Telefon-Tree, kein Gewicht.
Aber nicht mehr.
Ich bin nur ein normaler Kunde mit einer Maschine,
die niemand weiß, wie man sie repariert.
Und ich weiß nicht über dich.
Aber das ist ein Zahnbürger-Totem.
Na, Leute, das war's von mir.
Ihr könnt dieses Video mit euren Freunden,
mit euren Twitter-Followern,
mit dem Internet.
Ich denke, dass mehr Leute darüber wissen müssen.
Wenn ihr dieses Video genossen habt,
gebt es bitte ein Like.
Wenn ihr es nicht getan habt,
dann ist das andere Button auch okay.
Schaut auch einige andere tolle Videos an,
die ich in der Vergangenheit gemacht habe.
Sie sind wundervoll.
Und ihr lernt sehr viel.
Aber das Wichtigste ist,
dass ihr immer wieder hier seid.
Das ist ja gut.
Ich bin immer noch verrückt.
Das Video, nachdem ich mein erstes Video
über das iMac-Pro VESA-Mount-Wohs veröffentlicht habe,
das ich schon erlebt habe,
das solltet ihr definitiv hier klicken,
wenn ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt.
Ich habe mich entschieden,
zurück in den Apple-Store zu gehen.
Warum?
Nun, das könnte ein Erfrischungspunkt sein.
Nicht nur hat die Genius-Bar
die Rückseite meines iMacs absolut zerstört,
sondern auch die Stand-Stange während der Reparation.
Leute, ich hab das jetzt erst gecheckt.
Genius-Bar ist die Bezeichnung für den Apple-Store.
Das ist die Bezeichnung für den Apple-Store.
Ich dachte, mit Genius-Bar ist...
Also, Genius ist der Typ im Apple-Store, war mir klar.
Aber ich dachte, mit Bar ist irgendein Teil
von dem Anschlussleiste gemeint.
Das ist der...
Ach, das ist...
Deswegen sieht das da auch so aus
wie im Hipster-Veggie-Salatladen.
Weil das eine Bar ist.
Eine Genius-Bar.
Aber das neue VESA-Kit, das sie installiert haben,
das Apple-Store installiert hat,
brach wieder.
Vor allem, weil sie unbekannt zu mir
einen blühen Threadlocker,
der überhaupt nicht benutzt werden sollte.
Es ist nicht notwendig und wurde nicht in das Kit eingestellt.
Der Chat freut sich, dass er mal was schneller gecheckt hat als ich.
... sehr schwierig zu entfernen.
Aber egal, hier war ich wieder.
Mit einem gebrochenen iMac, wieder.
Nur dieses Mal war es in einer viel schlechteren Kosmetik-Kondition.
Danke, Apple.
Also ging ich zurück in den Store.
Und als ich in den Store kam,
habe ich gefragt, die Managern zu sehen.
Und hier ist die Konversation, die wir hatten.
Und wenn ich den Stand wieder anlege,
habe ich gemerkt, dass es nicht gut funktioniert.
Ich bin einfach nicht zufrieden
mit der Qualität der Reparation.
Und dann kann ich sagen,
dass sie diesen Mounting-Hook verwendet haben.
Also haben sie natürlich die Maschine geöffnet
und alles rausgelassen und das wieder ausgewählt.
Aber wenn das die Arbeit ist,
die wir hier und den Stand erhalten haben,
dann bin ich nicht zufrieden
mit der Qualität der internen Reparation.
Ich habe das Ganze durchgeschaut.
Sie wollten es nachher wieder machen.
Und ich schaute an diesen Fuß,
und dachte mir,
dass das nie funktioniert.
Denn diese waren so fest,
dass sie nicht aufhören konnten.
Aber das war wirklich gut gemacht.
Ich glaube, das war das erste Mal,
dass wir die Outers ausprobiert haben.
Das ist ziemlich Standard.
Aber diese waren definitiv uns.
Wenn das von uns aus gemacht wurde,
müssen wir uns darum kümmern, oder?
Ich weiß das, ich habe das gesehen.
Können wir uns ein paar Optionen anschauen?
Ich weiß, dass mir das hier anstrengend wäre.
Ich weiß, dass alles innen gut gemacht wurde.
Ich weiß, dass es innen gut ist,
aber es kann auch innen nicht passieren.
Ich verstehe das auch.
Wir haben ein paar Dinge, die für dich funktionieren könnten.
Was schaust du dir da an?
Wir haben uns gerade ein Video angeguckt,
wie Apple es geschafft hat,
ihr eigenes Zeug kaputt zu reparieren.
Das ist jetzt das zweite Video davon,
wo er mit dem Apple Store ist
und sich aufregt.
Ich möchte dir ein paar Optionen geben,
und dann kannst du wählen, was du willst.
Option 1 ist,
wir kaufen uns ein neues Backhaus.
Wir nehmen das Backhaus aus
und starten das neue Auto und
bauen ein neues Auto ein.
Wir können die Schrauben bewegen,
aber ich bin mir sicher, wir können was ausarbeiten.
Das ist die Option 1.
Option 2 ist,
wir haben den App Store,
und wir können unsere Computer
in der App Store anbinden
und wir können dein Computer
wiederholen.
Ich würde das gerne, wenn du das möchtest.
Vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das dort nennt.
Ich bin einfach aus dem Parkingplatz gegangen und dachte mir, was zum Teufel ist das?
Was soll man für ein Leben tun?
Ich mache YouTube-Videos über Apple-Produkte.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Ja, das ist ziemlich cool.
Vergesst nicht, darüber zu reden, bitte.
Tja, RIP würde ich sagen.
Ist schon passiert, es ist zu spät.
Too late.
So I did walk out of the store with a brand new iMac.
But I asked myself the question, would they have done this for anyone?
Now look, I'm a nobody, but my video had picked up a fair amount of traction already
when I went into the store, and one of the Apple Store employees mentioned it.
What the hell is up, was das?
Oh, nobody würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Gut, wer weiß nicht, wer weiß nicht, wie es von mir ausgesehen hat.
... that he had already seen the video.
Now, I'd like to think that Apple would have given a brand new computer to anyone.
But given the fact that they tried to send me out of the store with a busted stand and
iMac in the first place, hoping that I wouldn't notice even after the manager told the geniuses
that, quote,
I looked at this foot and I said, you guys, this is never gonna work.
I'm not so sure.
Vielleicht sind es doch keine so geniuses.
The story doesn't get over, however, because the next day I got a call from a liaison at
Apple Executive Relations, who admitted to me that he was calling me because he wanted
to speak with me.
Das ist ja witzig!
Das ist ja witzig.
It was a pleasure to speak with you.
Ja, ja.
... Apple Executive Relations, who admitted to me that he was calling me because Apple's
social media team had seen my video and the multiple articles written on various websites
about the incidents and the information had gotten sent up the chain.
He asked me first and foremost if the store had replaced my entire computer with a new
one, because anything short of that would have been unacceptable.
Natürlich.
Oh, jetzt gucken sich das die krassen Apple-Engineers an, ja.
Vielleicht hätten sie sich das mal vorher angucken sollen, bevor sie das quasi offiziell verkaufen und es ist Crap.
Wow, das ist Epoch, das ist Epoch.
Aber auch wenn das wahr ist, wie ist das meine Furcht?
Wenn etwas, was Clay,
die End-User-Installung ist, aber in einer Art und Weise gestaltet wird, in der der übrige User, der es installiert hat, einen hohen Risiko hat, es zu zerbrechen, das ist nicht die Furcht der User.
Das ist die Furcht der User. Das sind Apples. Das ist ein schlechtes Design.
Und für den Rekord, ich bin nicht der einzige Idiot, der Probleme hatte, dieses Ding zu entfernen.
Ich habe eine interessante E-Mail, die sagt,
Hey Quinn, ich arbeite für einen großen Game-Developer, in dem ich die Produktion von mehreren Teams betreue.
Während wir von PCs zu Apple-Development-Maschinen, speziell der iMac-Pro-Line, transitionieren,
wo wir mehrere VESA-Mount-Arrays benutzen, die an jeder unserer Teams-Desken stehen,
ist die Produktionzeit wichtig und unser Achilles-Helm ist, dass die Mounts nicht installiert werden.
Von den acht iMac-Pros in einem Bereich, haben fünf die VESA-Mount-Array servicen müssen.
Oh, das ist ja fehl.
Fünf, das sind 60 Prozent, übrigens.
Zwei wurden während der Installation gebraucht.
Alle Probleme wurden durch Schrauben erforscht.
Unsere IT-Betreiber sind gut getraut und haben jede Unit unter Apple-Guideleien behandelt,
nur um den Mount zu brechen.
Wir freuen uns auf die Transition zu Macs und freuen uns auf deine Geschichte,
um Apple eine Lösung zu finden.
Sie sind ein großer Game-Developer mit trainierten IT-Spezialisten und sie haben das gleiche Problem.
Ob du Apple gut oder schlecht an Design und Engineering glaubst,
ist es unmöglich zu glauben, dass Apple das in ihren Testen nicht erkannt hat.
Es ist mein Wunsch, dass Apple's Verkäufer,
der sie produziert,
entweder bescheuert hat,
ein paar Pfanne gesichert hat und
ohne Apple QC-Sendung des Produktes erhöht hat,
das wäre Apples Furcht,
oder dass Apple diese fehlenden VESA-Unit-Sendungen bemerkt hat,
weil ihre Kosten-Benefit-Analysen
bemerkt haben, dass das Re-Tooling und das Re-Design
für diese selten verwendeten VESA-Sendungen
auf einem noch seltener verkauften iMac Pro
viel teurer wäre, als nur fehlende Units zu fixieren.
Das ist auch Apples Furcht.
In jedem Fall macht Apple das nicht gut aus.
Diese Enttäuschung wird weiter erhöht,
durch den Fakt, dass Apple sehr klar unabhängig ist,
Enterprise-Level-Support für ihre Pro-Produkte zu bieten.
Dell, HP und andere PC-Konzerne bieten sofort
und oftens auch auf Sitz-Support für sogar Low-End-Produkte.
Währenddessen verfehlt Apple spezielle Unterstützung
für alles, was von Enterprise-Partnern abhängt.
Auch wenn man sich diesen 5.000 Dollar plus Pro-Komputer
Okay, wir wissen jetzt, wo es ausgeht.
Okay, schon mal nicht so gute Bewertung.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal das letzte Video an.
Das hat bestimmt...
Das hat bestimmt... Buckle up.
Ja, das hat schlechte Bewertung,
weil es die Apple-Fanboys wieder nicht vertragen,
dass einer was über Apple sagt.
So, mal Comments lesen.
Mistake was purchased 5K iMac Pro.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Mistake.
Das finde ich auch witzig, dass sie Genius heißen, ja.
Ich will ein paar Apple-Fanboys sehen.
Wo sind die Apple-Fanboys?
Die müssen da sein, wenn es 9K Dislikes hat.
Das sind immer geil, die Leute, die dann erzählen, wie super,
qualifiziert sie sind zum Schrauben eindrehen.
Man muss Mechaniker sein, um Schrauben einzudrehen in Apple-Wesamount.
Ist klar.
Was ein dämliches Comment.
Die Apple-Fanboys sind wieder am starten.
Was ein dämliches...
Why are you calling Apple support?
Weil es ein fucking 5K-Rechner ist, der so von Apple verkauft wurde.
Go to mechanic, he will remove the screw for you.
Alter, was Leute, ey.
Ich verstehe nicht, was man davon hat, wenn man eine Firm... wenn man... wenn man die
ganzen Firmen verwendet.
verteidigt. Ich verstehe das wirklich nicht.
Es ist egal, ob das eine Hardware-Hersteller ist,
ob das ein
Game-Hersteller ist. Es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es hat zum Beispiel auch überhaupt keinen Sinn,
jetzt irgendwie der übelste Call of Duty
Fanboy oder Battlefield oder
Apex oder Fortnite oder sonst
was zu sein. Weil ganz ehrlich,
die scheißen
auf das. Das ist denen egal.
Warum sollte man da Fanboyen?
Man sollte gucken, dass sie sich
ordentlich benehmen und wenn nicht,
dann darf man das doch kritisieren.
Es ist doch jetzt
es wird niemals der Fall
eintreten, ja. Wenn jetzt
irgendjemand sagt, keine Ahnung,
wenn jetzt irgendwie einer, sag mal,
einen validen Kritikpunkt an Fortnite
hat. Ich kenne mich mit Fortnite nicht aus. Nehmen wir es mal
als Beispiel, weil es saubekannt
ist, das Game, ja. So.
Und das dauert dann keine
fünf Sekunden, da kommt der übelste
Fortnite-Fanboy an und sagt, ey, du
scheiß Huso, hast keinen Rest, keinen Plan.
Und willst einfach nur Fortnite haten.
Ja, das ist immer so die Standard-Antwort, so nach dem Motto,
du willst das immer alles haten.
So. Wo ist das Problem?
Und meint
es wird nie der Fall eintreten,
dass Epic auf einmal
sagt, oh, da ist
ein Fanboy. Oh, der kriegt
von uns jetzt was kostenlos, weil er so schön gefanboyt
hat. Wie?
Die sagen, Alter, ist das ein dummer
Typ, ey. Einer von drei Milliarden
dämlichen Fanboys, den wir in die Kohlehause-Tasche
ziehen können. Das hat überhaupt
keinen Sinn.
Bestimmte Produkte
oder bestimmte Firmen
zu fanboyen,
wenn sie Scheiße baut,
zu verteidigen. Man kann von was
Fan sein, was gut ist, klar,
aber man sollte nie den Blick darauf
verlieren, wenn es halt
fehlt manchmal,
wenn die irgendwie Scheiße
bauen oder so.
Was hat man denn davon, wenn man einfach
hirnlos was fanboyt? Das sehe ich
bei Apple-Leuten total oft.
Ich sehe es auch bei Playstation-Fanboys total
oft. Wobei es
die aktuelle Generation, die beste
Konsole meiner Meinung nach immer noch die PS4 ist.
Das ist schlimm.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Das kann ich echt nicht nachvollziehen.
Man hat doch absolut nichts von.
Und ich glaube
ja, das liegt
zu einem ganz großen
Teil daran, weil
die Leute so psychisch
irgendwie ein Problem haben,
weil sie denken,
sie haben
jetzt quasi
sich Produkt X
gekauft. Und sollte
man jetzt
berechtigte Kritik
daran akzeptieren,
würde man sich ja eingestehen,
dass man
eventuell
das Falsche gekauft hat.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine? Mal angenommen, bei dieser
ganzen Diskussion damals Xbox vs.
Playstation. Ich finde, es ist für mich
schon nahezu ein Fakt,
dass bei der 360 und
bei der PS3
das Xbox Live
meilenweit vor dem PSN war. Gibt es
Tischpunkte, warum?
Und es hatten ganz viele Leute, ich meine,
PSN hatte auch Vorteile. Es hat zum Beispiel damals
nichts gekostet. Aber wenn man sich mal rein
anguckt, wie gut es funktioniert hat, war
Xbox Live einfach vorne.
Und da hatten ganz viele Leute
diese simple Sache und du konntest denen
10 Punkte aufzählen, die eindeutig
besser sind an Xbox Live.
Party Chat, Party Chat, ohne
Scheiß. PS3 hat kein Party Chat.
Du hast es den Leuten gesagt
und es kamen einfach
nur dumme Antworten.
Weil ich glaube,
oder ich denke zumindest, die Leute
haben ein Problem damit, sich einzugestehen,
dass die andere Plattform was
besser kann, weil sie dann vielleicht
irgendwie die Liebe
zu ihrer Plattform nicht
in Frage gestellt sehen
oder so. Ganz merkwürdig. Ich kann
das nicht erklären. Ich bin jetzt nicht der geile
Psychologen-Mensch, ja. Aber irgendwie
sowas muss das sein.
Ja, wir können das ja gleich weiterkommen.
Ich will erst mal nochmal Comments gucken.
Apple is gay.
Zumindest Tim Cook ist gay.
Sind gar nicht so viele Apple-Fanboys am Start.
You're stupid to put
the Visa Mount on it again
after it blocked.
Der Kram wurde mit Visa Mount verkauft.
Das muss funktionieren.
Nein, das sind nicht Apple-Employees. Apple-Employees
verstehen das. Das sind dumme
Apple-Fanboys.
Oh Mann. So, und was sollen wir jetzt
gucken? Leute, wir können jetzt nicht so viele Videos
gucken. Wir müssen morgen früh, machen wir schon
Aufwach-Stream und gucken wieder Videos.
Können wir nicht den ganzen Tag irgendwelche YouTube-Videos gucken?
Oh, was geht's
hier? Apple Genius Bar
strikes again.
Okay, was macht denn die Apple Genius
Bar? Okay, dann
gucken wir uns das jetzt an.
Das letzte Video, was wir heute gucken.
Ist doch schon 23 Uhr.
Nuts 89
Pog Subscriber.
Dankeschön.
Äh, hab ich was übersehen?
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Dich hau das, das ist besser.
Okay, dann schauen wir das andere.
Oh ja.
Ja, immer. Immer.
Endlich Tim Apple.
Genius Bar.
Das heißt echt so, ich bin
schockiert.
Was zum Teufel geht mit denen ab?
This is the image of an Apple
store that the company wants you to see.
Masses of customers hungry for the
latest product.
Leute, ihr werdet mich nie in so einer
Schlange finden.
Ach ja, das hab ich schon mal
gesehen. Das hab ich schon mal gesehen,
dass wenn man dann reinkommt,
dass dann die Apple-Dudes stehen
und die applaudieren. Ich versteh's
jetzt irgendwie nicht so ganz, warum das so
ein krasser Hype ist, aber
okay.
Jawoll, ich hab 1500 Euro
ausgegeben. Yay!
Ich versteh's nicht.
Das ist voll Sackmäßig.
Our team came to a
Toronto Apple store with a Macbook
computer that had a common problem.
The screen had stopped working.
It's like very dim when I try to turn it on.
Okay.
So, what I'll do is I'll jump out the back and have a look on the inside.
Sure.
Da wird's gemast jetzt.
Alright, thank you for your patience.
So, yeah.
So, there's a lot of liquid that's gotten on the inside.
So, I took a little picture.
The little red dots here, they're normally white and it means that they've come in contact
with liquid.
So, for it to be basically all over the whole computer, it means that something's gone
through the whole thing.
So, with that, we'd need to be looking at replacing quite a few things.
Okay.
Warum genau müsst ihr das Case replacen, wenn innen Wasser war?
Da kannst du dir was Neues für kaufen.
Previously, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Ähm, ich meine, das kostet sehr nah an dem Preis, um ein neues Computer zu kaufen.
In Bezug auf das Fixieren in der Stube, nein.
Ah, ah.
Ripp.
Viele Apple-Kunden haben gleiche Erfahrungen getroffen.
Und so haben wir entschieden...
Ich glaube, ich überlege mir das nochmal mit dem Apple-Kaufner.
... um die Diagnose zu überprüfen.
Auf 1. Avenue in Manhattan gibt es einen kleinen Computer-Repair-Store,
von Louis Rossmann.
He started fixing computers in college.
Ach, der kennt...
Den habe ich schon mal...
Ich glaube, von dem habe ich schon mal was geguckt.
Der kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Overall, Apple tries to get you to purchase a new device,
instead of a pair-year-old one.
His videos often draw millions of views.
Digga, was wolltest du von Apple kaufen?
Ich wollte einen...
Also, ich habe ja aktuell einen iPhone 6, das wird nicht mehr supported.
Jetzt habe ich einen iPhone XR.
Und ich wollte jetzt noch eins kaufen, aber das musste ich ja nicht selbst kaufen.
Ich habe jetzt überlegt, ob ich ihn noch für meine Mutter eins kaufe,
weil die hat so ein altes Samsung-Club-Handy, Siemens-Club-Handy.
Was haben sie denn? Siemens? Irgendwas olles.
Und da weiß ich nicht genau, was ich kaufen soll.
Irgendwie sind wir so zu Apple-Videos gekommen. Keine Ahnung.
Wir haben ihm den Computer gebracht, den der Apple-Store in Toronto gesagt hat,
dass er nicht wert ist, ihn zu fixieren.
So, haben Sie einen Schlauch.
Also, das ist ein MacBook Pro, den der Apple-Store gesagt hat,
dass es 1200 Dollar kostet, um ihn zu fixieren, und es nicht wert war.
Gut, dann schauen wir mal, ob das wahr ist.
Glaubt ihr, ihr seht das Apple-Logo da?
Glaubt ihr, das Video habe ich schon mal gesehen?
Und schaut, wenn ich ein Licht nehme und es da drüber lege, werdet ihr es sehen.
Wahrscheinlich ist einfach die Hintergrundbeleuchtung kaputt, ne?
Alles auf dem Bild.
Glaubt ihr, das habe ich schon mal gesehen?
Und wenn ich es hier drüber lege,
seht ihr, dass da ein Kursor da ist und es bewegt sich.
Also, die meisten von den Bildschirmen funktionieren richtig.
Es ist nur so, dass das Hinterlicht nicht funktioniert.
Das könnte entweder wegen einem schlechten Bildschirm, einem schlechten Motherboard oder einem schlechten Kabel sein.
Aber wir werden es nachher herausfinden, wenn wir es öffnen.
Okay.
Und wenn ich abrichte.
Also, schauen wir mal, was da drinnen ist.
Nun, hier wird das Bildschirm mit dem Computer verbunden.
Okay.
Also, das erste, was ich tun möchte, ist, das Bereich zu überprüfen, um zu sehen, wie es aussieht.
Seht ihr den Pin, der da drüben steckt?
Okay.
Also, dieser Pin ist wahrscheinlich der Pin für das Hinterlicht.
Und wie ihr seht, wird es wahrscheinlich nicht in Kontakt bringen, weil es nach außen bewegt ist.
Und ich habe mein Set von Zeichnungen hier.
Und ich werde versuchen, das zurück in den Slot zu drücken.
Und versuchen, es zurück in seine Hüfte zu bringen.
So.
So was würde ich mir übrigens auch gerne kaufen.
So ein...
Oh, wie heiß?
Das ist ja kein normales Mikroskop.
Das ist so ein...
So ein für zwei Augen...
Wie nennt sich das nochmal?
Wie nennt sich das denn nochmal?
Weiß das jemand?
Das ist so ein... so ein... so ein... so ein...
Pinocolanee...
Das ist irgendwie so ein...
Ach, ich habe es vergessen.
So was würde ich mir auch gerne kaufen.
Das ist richtig nice, wenn man was löten muss und so.
Fernglas.
Genau, das ist...
Das ist richtig nice.
Das ist richtig nice, also das hat man ja auch richtig gut gemacht.
Also das ist richtig...
Das hat man ja auch richtig gut gemacht.
Also wir haben hier einen Kabel.
Ja.
Dann haben wir ein Kabel.
So, das ist wirklich...
So ein...
Also ihr habt euch jetzt auch noch ein eigenes Kabel mitgebracht.
Ja.
So, jetzt können wir das nochmal umschalten.
Okay.
So, und...
Das ist jetzt natürlich schon normal.
Das ist also ein sehr gunstiges Kabel, oder?
Ja.
Und der ist richtig gut.
Also, das ist wirklich super quanstig.
Und das ist wirklich super gut.
Das ist wirklich super agreed, wenn man das so aufschreibt.
Alright, so, let's plug this back in and hope for the best.
Alright, as you can see, we've got an apple and we have a light.
Eats!
Yeah, now...
That took you like one and a half minutes.
Easy.
Maybe.
Easy as a book.
So if I walk in off the street with this problem, what would you charge for the repair you just did?
If somebody wanted me to just bend the pin back, I wouldn't charge them for that.
I would say, I'm going to rework your original cable.
That may not last long term, but here, it's free.
If they wanted us to replace the cable, depending on the model, anywhere from 75 to 150,
depending on the difficulty of opening that model.
But something like this, we wouldn't charge for it.
And 99% of the time, just bending the pin back, it'll allow it to last until the end of the life of the computer.
We asked Apple to respond to this incident.
This is going to cost more than $1,000.
To fix it entirely will cost more than $1,000?
Yeah.
And to the widespread allegations of similar corporate behavior.
They declined to provide us both...
...but issued a statement claiming their customers are best served by Apple's certified experts using genuine parts.
Genius.
They denied systematically...
Oh, the geniuses verwenden genuine parts.
That's natürlich...
...prestimating repair costs.
How often do people show up here with the Apple store telling them it can't be fixed or it's too expensive to fix?
Somewhere between 10 and 30 times a day.
No kidding?
Yeah.
In San Luis Obispo, California, iFixit is probably the most successful third-party repairer.
The business tests cell phones and computers, diagnoses problems that regularly occur and develops the tools and techniques to repair them.
They sell the tools and repair manuals over the internet.
iFixit has 125 employees and makes $21 million a year.
The business is owned by Kyle Wiens, who is also a leading spokesman for the national Right to Repair movement.
It used to be that if you bought something, you'd be able to get it fixed when you needed to.
And over time, we've lost that ability.
Whether it's a vacuum or a television or a laptop, it's increasingly more challenging to get access to the information that you need.
Or for local shops to get the right...
Ja, gut, Apple hat ja auch kein Interesse dran.
...and a set of legislation that would restore that ability to fix your own stuff.
How does Apple fit into that question?
Apple's perspective is that they want complete control over the device from the moment that you buy it,
all the way through the end of life.
Ja, klar.
And Right to Repair takes some of that control away from them and puts it in the hands of the world.
Da sind sie ja alle scharf drauf.
And that's where, for a manufacturer to say, we're making a product and we're putting it out in the world
and we're going to control every aspect of what happens after the fact, is complete lunacy.
We asked Kyle Wiens to show us some of the tricks Apple uses to foil easy repairs, starting with non-standard screws.
So this is the Pentalobe screw. It's on the bottom of the MacBook Pro.
And it's...
And Torx-Stelz, oder?
So you can see, it's not like any screw that you've seen before.
Nee, das ist kein normaler Torx.
It turns out that Apple invented their own screw.
It's purely, they want to make the devices harder for normal people to open with the tools that they already have laying around.
Then Apple started gluing in batteries.
This is an iPhone 8, and this is the battery, and it's glued in.
And that's unfortunate, it doesn't need to be glued in. Batteries didn't used to be glued in.
Ja, wozu auch?
Is it one of those kind of pull-and-release caps?
Yeah, 3M calls them Command Adhesives.
Right.
Okay.
WTF, warum ist diese Scheißbatterie festgeklippt?
Na gut, dass du nichts machen kannst, natürlich.
On some Apple phones, the home button would have to be replaced if the screen cracked.
It was a cheap and easy repair.
But then Apple reprogrammed the operating system to detect non-authorized home buttons and the phone would suddenly stop working.
Yeah, it would be like if you're driving your car and maybe you changed out the tires and you had aftermarket tires
and then all of a sudden Tesla pushes out a software update and your car stops driving because of those aftermarket tires.
This stems from a mentality that they're the center of the universe and nobody else is doing anything with their products.
Apple insists that its products are best serviced by its own staff and clearly sees unauthorized third-party repair businesses as the enemy.
Louis Rossmann and iFixit have received legal threats from the company.
Die wollen ja auch 1.000 Euro Repair verkaufen.
I would be happy with a rollback on the Intellectual Property Law and the Immigration and Customs Enforcement Law that allow people to be either thrown in jail or prosecuted for importing parts and for showing a schematic.
Because Apple writes the manual, they own the copyright to it.
And so if you post that manual online, they'll send you a legal takedown threat saying that's our copyright.
Demnächst reparierst du ein iPhone und musst in den Knast.
The fuck?
If you don't take it down, we'll sue you.
If you don't take it down, we'll sue you for up to $150,000 in damages per incident.
And those legal threats have really put a damper on repair information online.
The tide may be turning against Apple on the right to repair issue.
This is the New York State Legislature, where Louis Rossmann and the right to repair movement have set up a repair café to put on a show for politicians.
Inwiefern wollen die einen anzeigen?
While you have shared original handbooks, for example.
Two or three do you think is covering up the battery connection?
Probably this one.
So far this year, 17 US states have introduced right to repair legislation that would force Apple and other companies to provide repair manuals and spare parts to third party repair businesses.
I'd like Apple to change by acknowledging that if they're not willing to do certain jobs, maybe somebody else would.
And to just... I... I agree with you.
I'm not even asking them to extend an olive branch.
I'm just asking them to stop extending the knife.
What happens when the first state actually passes one of these proposed legislations?
Well, this is where it gets really interesting.
The moment that one state passes things, the dam is going to burst.
So if Ontario decided we're going to pass a right to repair legislation,
that could actually pass a right to repair for the world.
Because manufacturers aren't going to provide products differently to people in one jurisdiction.
They want to simplify their operation.
The right to repair movement has put a spotlight on some of Apple's predatory business practices.
I mean, that cost is very close to the cost of buying a new computer.
And many Apple customers are starting to wonder whether the company really has their best interest at heart.
Nö.
Die besten Interests haben die, um Kohle zu machen.
Die haben noch nicht wirklich irgendjemand, der den Kram gekauft hat, da im Best Interest oder so.
Das ist denen doch vollkommen wurscht.
Das sagen zwar alle immer, aber das sagen die einzig und allein nur, wenn man dabei ein gutes Gefühl hat.
Schau mal den Artikel an.
Wir haben jetzt genug Apple-Zeug geguckt.
Ähm, den haben wir hier am Start.
Tufu, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pock.
Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Subscriber, nice.
Was, wenn du eins haben willst, jetzt ein gutes Wasser und...
...stereoskopisches, äh, Dings?
Ja, genau, sowas in der Richtung wollte ich mir kaufen, richtig.
Ja, sowas.
Das ist richtig nice, wenn man was löten muss.
Weil man halt es direkt sieht.
USB Mikro... äh, USB Mikroskope haben halt das Problem.
Du hast so ein doofes Delay und du guckst nicht dahin, wo du lötest.
Das ist halt Müll.
Arkenas99, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pock.
Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime, Prime.
Da ist halt auch eine Kamera drauf.
Okay, das ist echt cool.
Mal ausprobieren.
Bookmarken wir das mal.
Was kostet...
Wo ist denn der Unterschied?
Achso.
Nein, es ist nur ohne das Gestell dabei.
Moment, der Versand kostet 84 Euro.
What the fuck?
Okay, da muss ich mal gucken.
Das stimmt, Night.
Also der Software-Support von Apple ist wirklich nice.
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Ich bin begeistert, wie lange das iPhone 6
supportet wurde.
Dachte die Quali bei AliExpress ist kacke?
Nö, das kommt drauf an, was du kaufst.
AliExpress ist ja im Prinzip nur der Marketplace.
Wenn du da irgendwie so ein
Roborock S50
Staubsaugerroboter kaufst, ist der bei AliExpress
genauso gut, wie wenn du den hier kaufst.
Leute, eigentlich wollte ich gar nicht so lange streamen.
Ich bin jetzt schon wieder...
Wie lange bin ich jetzt am Start hier?
Wollte ich das mal an, 2 Stunden?
Wollte eigentlich nur kurz gucken und Upload checken,
ob das alles funktioniert.
Ähm...
Ja.
Akenas neuen neuen Switch...
Ne, den hatte ich schon, ne?
Aber trotzdem, Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, mal gucken, wie viel Aufrufe hat mein aktuelles WIT.
Oh, 13k. Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
50, 50,6k.
Ich hab das erst vor ein paar Stunden hochgeladen.
Das ist echt nicht schlecht für, quasi,
innerhalb von ein paar Stunden 15k.
Das ist nice.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Was für ein Kabelmodem hast du?
Ich hab jetzt eine Connect-Box.
Von Unity Media.
Und morgen werde ich mal ausprobieren,
ob das funktioniert.
Dass man die in Bridge-Modus versetzt.
Und dann kann ich direkt meinen
Router verwenden, ohne dass ich dann nochmal
das Unity-Media-Ding dazwischen hab.
Und dann kann ich direkt meinen Router verwenden, ohne dass ich dann nochmal
Und dann kann ich direkt meinen Router verwenden, ohne dass ich dann nochmal das Unity-Media-Ding dazwischen hab.
Machst du zurzeit eigentlich gut Abos?
Naja, es ist weit davon entfernt,
was ich früher an Abos gemacht hab,
wo ich hauptsächlich Call of Duty Zeug gemacht hab,
einer der wenigen Channels in Deutschland war.
Und vor allem die Games noch richtig gehypt waren.
Ist natürlich...
Früher hab ich 400 Abos am Tag oder so gemacht.
Jetzt mach ich so
30 bis 80,
je nachdem,
was ich hochgeladen hab.
Hier sieht man es auch ganz gut.
Leider ist Social Blade kaputt.
Also jetzt mach ich so hier.
Ja, das stimmt halt nicht,
weil Social Blade kaputt ist.
Social Blade ist kaputt,
weil YouTube der Meinung war,
es ist zu kompliziert
für Zuschauer,
es ist zu kompliziert für Zuschauer,
Abo-Zahlen zu erkennen.
Deswegen kürzt YouTube jetzt
die Abo-Zahlen.
Ich versteh's nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hab am liebsten
immer auf Social Blade geguckt, zu kurzen
Übersicht.
Leider sieht man das gar nicht.
Social Blade ist zu kurz.
So die Sachen, wo ich
irgendwie meine 2 Millionen Views im Monat hatte,
halt, wie gesagt,
zu Black Ops 1 und so Zeiten,
sind leider nicht mehr drauf. Das geht hier erst los.
Ab
Ende 2016.
Meiner Meinung nach solltest du
IT-Videos machen, wie zum Beispiel Linus Tech Tips.
Problem ist mit IT-Videos machen.
Also ich würde auch...
Ich mache auch...
mehr im Prinzip. Ich mache jetzt schon mehr.
Und ich werde auch in Zukunft mehr machen.
Ähm...
Aber ich stell mich halt nicht
vor die Kamera. Das ist so das Problem dabei.
Das Isle of Cookies
is now following. Macht er das?
POC!
Hast du...
Hast du zwischen 2 Pokerrunden
gefollowt?
Nice!
Cool zu sehen,
dass es das noch gibt.
Aua! Deutsche Linus Tech Tips, ja.
Der macht das aber auch gut.
Der macht
das aber auch gut.
Ähm...
Muss anfangen zu rappen. Ja, mittlerweile eher, ne?
Mittlerweile
ist jeder... Jeder muss
irgendwie... Sogar Katja Grasawitze
oder wie sie heißt, hat jetzt mittlerweile irgendwelche
komischen Songs, ey. Warum
macht jeder Songs?
Warum? Und dann ist das vor allem auch noch
irgendein Autotune-Crap immer.
Wenn das wenigstens ordentliche Musik
wär, ja.
Der Rauter meine ich natürlich.
Ja, also
wie gesagt, eigentlich wollte ich jetzt aufgehen, weil ich
wollte nur ganz kurz testen, ob mein Unity Media
Zeug ordentlich funktioniert.
Aber wie gesagt, mit Abos is echt ganz gut
zurzeit.
Deswegen mach ich ja auch immer mein Abo-Sellout.
Tatsächlich noch in 2
Turnieren drinne. Muss ja gucken, wo
er bleibt, ne?
Naja. Du bist ja bekanntlich
im Sellout-Modus. Also, wie viel für den
Max-FPS-Song?
In Twitch-Subscriber
oder in Donation?
Um was ging's? Achso.
Meint gar nicht mein Video, meint hier.
Gar nicht mitgekriegt das, was hochgeladen wurde.
Ähm...
Also ich würd sagen, für den Max-FPS-Song
da brauchts schon ein bisschen
was.
Da brauchts schon ein bisschen
was. Ich würd
sagen, bei 300.000
Abos
bei 300.000 Abos
können wir uns das mal überlegen.
Also
das wird ja noch, das wird ja schon noch
so ein Jahr dauern,
wenn das in der Geschwindigkeit weitergeht.
Eigentlich, ne?
Ich hatte ja vor,
ein bisschen, ähm...
mit anderen was aufzunehmen.
Ich wollt wieder mit Hardwarerat ein bisschen was aufnehmen.
Und, ähm...
Ja, mit ein paar Leuten, die ich noch von damals kenn.
Ich denke mal, das bringt dann auch
bisschen was.
Aber...
Sagen wir mal so, ich rechne mal...
Ich rechne mal mal so ungefähr...
Es werden ja auch immer mehr Subs, das seh ich ja.
Am Anfang waren es irgendwie 30 am Tag,
jetzt sind wir schon bei teilweise 80 am Tag.
Neun, inklusive D-Abos.
Ansonsten sind's ja, sind's ja viel mehr.
Ähm...
Das Gartenvideo ja, unbedingt.
Aber es ist ja bald soweit, ne?
Es ist ja hier schon...
Ich mein, es ist September, es schneit bald wieder.
Und ich dachte mir, das könnte auch mal
bisschen ordentlich was bringen.
Aber ich denk mal, ein halbes Jahr brauchen wir
schon auch bis...
bis ich 300.000 hab.
Und dann machen wir vielleicht den MaxFPS-Song.
Der Keks-Stells-Song.
Mousefeud-Video.
Ja, ja, Mousefeud-Video ist
immer noch Garten-Stells.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädchen.
Ähm...
Mousefeud-Video.
Zwei Millionen Views.
Warum so viele Dislikes?
Habe ich viele Dislikes auf... echt?
Auch gar nicht viele Dislikes
auf dem letzten Video.
Hallo, Jungs.
Oh mein Gott! 18 Dislikes!
MonkaS.
MonkaS? MonkaS?
18 Dislikes.
Fuck! Das ist bloß
99,5678...
1,5%
äh, Like zu Dislike-Verhältnis.
...
Achso, du meinst gar nicht mich.
Gut, das kann ich jetzt wirklich nicht erkennen,
bei der Geschichte im Chat.
Naja, ähm...
Also, das verstehe ich nicht.
Das war so eine typische YouTube-Geschichte damals, ne?
Ich meine, in dem Video passiert...
Das hat zu Recht so viele Dislikes.
In dem Video passiert
nichts.
Außer, dass ich durch
einen zugeschneiten Garten laufe.
Aber ich meine, was ist
mit YouTube kaputt?
Und das hat es auf die Startseite geschafft.
Das einzige Video, was ich je hatte,
was auf der Startseite war,
das checke ich nicht.
Da war der YouTube-Algorithmus wieder
absolut big brain.
Ich habe es bis heute immer noch nicht verstanden.
Past Max.
Kein Schimmer. YouTube in a nutshell.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt, dass
sie die Verification-Badge
entfernen wollten?
Feder, wollten sie dir auch deine
Verification-Badge entfernen?
Den Haken neben dem Namen?
Das gab einen riesen Shitstorm,
Leute. Wenn man auf Twitter
guckt, auf YouTube sucht,
ähm...
Ach, dich wollen sie nicht, die
Verificationen.
Wieso das?
Weil sie ihre Bedingungen geändert
haben, dass du jetzt nur noch
verifiziert wirst, wenn du ein bekannter
Künstler aus irgendwie Fernsehmusik
sonst was bist und
ähm...
auch auf anderen Plattformen quasi
bekannt bist, ja?
Genau, das sollen nur die Leute behalten,
die außerhalb von YouTube Fame sind.
Und die haben quasi auch Channels, wollten
sie entverifizieren,
die teilweise Millionen
oder noch mehr Abos haben. Total
gestört. So, und es war ein riesen
Shitstorm, die sind alle
ausgeflippt hier, wenn man hier lang scrollt, hier
über YouTube und auf Twitter und auf Reddit.
Überall, die sind alle komplett
eskaliert, die Leute. Auch
im Blogpost,
auch im Blogpost von
ähm... von diesem, von
von dieser Änderung, waren irgendwie
430 Seiten, wo
YouTube geflamed wurde und heute Morgen
heute Morgen
stand dann, als man sich eingeloggt hat,
so nach dem Motto, ah, okay,
wir haben es uns anders überlegt,
wenn, wenn ihr schon eine Verification
Badge habt, dann
behaltet ihr die auch. Und das ist
das erste Mal, was ich
je mitbekommen habe,
wo YouTube
zurückgerudert ist. Ne,
nicht auf Twitch. Twitch nicht, ach, auf
Twitch ist eigentlich alles gut.
Man kann sich auf Twitch
so ein bisschen drüber aufregen, dass
auch hier mittlerweile viele
sagen wir mal, ähm, eine
VIP
Behandlung vielleicht genießen, aber
es ist aus Sicht von Twitch irgendwie auch nachvollziehbar,
ähm, dass manche wahrscheinlich
noch, sagen wir mal so, dass da
bei Twitch auch einiges mit
zweierlei Maß gemessen wird,
ja gut, aber ansonsten gibt es
eigentlich wenig, finde ich, an Twitch auszusetzen.
Und ganz ehrlich, auch wenn Ninja und
äh, manch anderer sich jetzt vielleicht noch überlegt
zu Mixer zu gehen, ich glaube
nicht, dass Mixer
irgendwie Twitch den Rang ablaufen wird, glaube
ich einfach nicht. Online Gaming
Warlord, ah, das ist mal ein Name,
Twitch Prime,
dankeschön. Bist du Twitch Partner?
Ja. So, Mixer,
was hat, was hat denn jetzt eigentlich, was
geht denn eigentlich so bei Ninja auf Mixer
jetzt? Watch.
Wie viel Zeit, ach so, das
bringt ja überhaupt nichts, dass man nach Subs guckt, ne?
Most recent clip,
251 Views,
lol. Aber nicht
viel, paar Streams.
Alter!
Das ist ja nix!
Mich würde echt interessieren,
das gucken wir jetzt mal auf Social Blade,
mich würde echt interessieren,
nicht Twitch,
Mixer können die jetzt auch,
mich würde echt interessieren, was Ninja so
für Zuschauer aktuell hat.
Der hat, glaube ich, eine Million bekommen von Microsoft,
der wird ordentlich
bekommen haben von Microsoft.
Das ist der Deal für die Rente, was der da gekriegt hat.
Garantiert.
So viel Poker kannst du gar nicht spielen, ne?
Für das, was der dafür gekriegt hat,
ne?
So, mehr als eine Million,
ja, glaube ich auch.
Glaube ich auch.
Ich könnte mir schon fast
vorstellen, dass man sich da an zwei Stellen im Millionenbereich
bewegt, also, ich mein,
ihm wird wahrscheinlich klar
sein, denke ich mal,
dass das Viewer und alles,
was technisch jetzt nicht unbedingt der große
Wurf ist, aber
es ist einfach für die Rente, ja?
Seine Frau und er, die haben einfach ausgesorgt
jetzt damit. Und
ganz ehrlich,
ich würde das auch machen.
Ich würde das auch machen.
Ich würde sogar,
ganz ehrlich, es würde mir zwar
schwerfallen, jetzt mal wirklich ernsthaft,
wenn jemand zu mir kommt und sagt,
Max, du kriegst zwei Millionen, gib mir deinen YouTube-Channel,
das würde ich
sofort machen.
Ähm,
es wäre natürlich beknackt irgendwo,
ja, wenn man sich überlegt,
zu sagen, ey, ähm,
irgendwie so zehn Jahre wegschmeißen,
aber, ganz ehrlich,
danach kann ich
immer noch was, danach würde ich einfach
einen neuen Channel machen, ja?
Aber, ganz ehrlich,
es hat ja auch keinen Sinn.
Es erzählen auf YouTube immer so nach dem Motto,
ey, ich würde euch nie irgendwie,
ich würde nie Sellout machen, ich würde nie
euch irgendwie, ähm,
verlassen und verraten und sonst was.
Ganz ehrlich, es kommt einfach nur auf die Summe an.
Und die meisten würden das machen.
Ja, deswegen, ganz easy.
Wer, wer
20 Subs giftet, kriegt einen Mod.
Ganz einfach.
Nee, aber, ähm,
das würde ich machen.
Wahrscheinlich sogar für weniger.
Aber ganz ehrlich, also wenn ich mir überlege,
also wenn jetzt einer ankommt
zu mir und sagt, Max, ich geb dir 50k,
dafür gibst du mir deinen YouTube-Channel,
dann würde ich sagen, kannst mich mal.
Niemals, ähm,
und selbst wenn er 100k
würde ich auch nicht machen.
Also ich würd's mir, alter Leute,
das war ein Witz.
Chuck96,
Gleich mal,
gleich mal Pay2Win raushauen, ey.
Alter.
Chuck96.
Oh man, jetzt wurscht es.
Ich würd's auch noch machen.
Versteh...
Fuck, Alter.
Warum?
Jetzt muss ich ihn modden, jetzt hab ich gelitten, ey.
Jetzt muss ich ihn modden.
Okay.
Wart mal, wie geht denn das jetzt?
Chuck96.
Warum nicht Chuck69?
Okay.
Ähm, Moment.
Wie macht man das jetzt überhaupt?
Ich hatte mal so einen Overlay,
wo das, wo das geht.
Was nicht SlashMod?
So, jetzt bist du Mod.
Easy Sellout.
So einfach kann's gehen.
Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Darf man das überhaupt?
Oder verstößt das gegen Twitch-Toss,
wenn man Mod-Rechte verkauft?
Huge Sellout, ey.
Wirst du heute noch Modern Warfare spielen?
Nee, ich geh jetzt ins Bett.
Es ist 23.30 Uhr.
Morgen penn ich aus
und Montag muss ich wieder 5.45 Uhr aufstehen.
Normalerweise hab ich ja montags frei,
aber ich muss nächste Woche auf so eine komische
Microsoft-Azure-Schulung,
wo ich eigentlich auf die Schulung selbst
sogar recht viel Bock habe,
aber wo ich keinen Bock drauf habe,
ist die Uhrzeit, wo das ist.
Guck mal, Leute.
Das bimmelt immer noch von den 20 Subs.
Das hört überhaupt nicht auf.
Azure, ja.
In your face, Azure.
Ich hab, glaub ich, noch jemanden übersehen.
Ich hab keinen übersehen.
Eine Güte, damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet,
aber Sellout is real. Easy.
Ich weiß, die Frage kam wahrscheinlich schon oft,
warum der Name hier auf Twitch.
Der Name ist eigentlich ziemlich beknackt
so im Nachhinein, weil es ein Account war,
mit dem ich nie vorhatte zu streamen.
Ich wollte damit überhaupt nicht streamen.
Ich hab mir einfach nur ein Account auf Twitch erstellt.
Ich glaub sogar damals von meinem Smartphone aus,
weil ich irgendwas schreiben wollte im Chat
und ich hab halt
irgendwas eingegeben.
Und da kam Wubblors raus,
weil das ist halt das typische Max-FPS-Speak, oder?
Passt schon, Wubblors.
So, und dann hab ich mir gedacht,
als ich angefangen wollte zu streamen,
eigentlich ist Wubblors gar nicht so schlecht,
weil
die Leute einen nicht sofort mit YouTube
in Verbindung bringen.
Das ist natürlich schlecht für Sellout,
aber der Anteil an Deppen auf YouTube
ist einfach ziemlich hoch.
Bei mir jetzt nicht so,
insgesamt.
Deswegen hab ich gedacht, es ist gar nicht so schlecht,
wenn man quasi das ankündigt,
aber nicht so direkt
quasi gefunden wird.
So, und deswegen
kommen dann nur die Leute von YouTube rüber,
die es halt sehen
und sich dafür interessieren und die ganzen Deppen bleiben weg.
So dachte ich mir das zumindest.
Ob das wirklich so ist,
weiß ich nicht, aber
es ist tatsächlich
im Vergleich zu YouTube
sind, also der Chat hier,
das ist wirklich angenehm, ja.
Es ist wirklich angenehm.
Es ist cool,
dass du es hier gefunden hast.
Nice.
Nachdem ich jetzt ja eh gerade im Sellout-Modus bin,
wir könnten ja was zusammen aufnehmen
für mehr Cross-Promotion.
Und ich weiß gar nicht,
machst du noch Videos?
Ich hab, glaube ich, zuletzt mal
vor einem Jahr oder so draufgeguckt
und da war nichts mehr.
Wäre dabei, nice.
Da überlege ich mir mal was.
Ich hab mir nämlich schon
eine Textdatei,
eine Notiz gemacht
für
für alle, mit denen ich
was aufnehmen könnte.
Da ist ganz schön viel dabei mittlerweile,
finde ich cool.
Ich muss die Leute aber erstmal fragen.
Mal gucken.
Genau, so richtig oldschool Zeug.
Ich weiß noch nicht so was.
Keine Ahnung. Hast du mal Modern Warfare 2 gespielt?
Hast du mal ausprobiert?
Hätte der Kaboom eventuell Bock?
Ich weiß nicht, kann ich mal fragen.
Genau, ich wollte ja mal bei Ninja gucken.
Also, ähm,
Daily Video Views, okay, das geht natürlich krass hoch.
Ich würde mal
Views allgemein pro Stream.
Also das ist, ich denke,
das ist mit Mixer schon
ganz schön
abwärts gegangen.
Ja, aber
wahnsinnig abwärts.
Wobei, hier ist er gewechselt, ne?
Na gut, hier ist, wo er hier mit diesem
mit dem Dings hier, wer war denn, mit irgendeinem Rapper
hat er ja, mit irgendeinem Hip-Hop-Typer da gestreamt.
Krass.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall bei ihm auch
auf Mixer.
Es sieht in Zahlen mäßig natürlich gut aus, wenn du kostenlos
summen kannst.
Aber insgesamt hat Mixer jetzt schon nicht
dazu beigetragen, dass es gerade irgendwie
mehr Leute geworden sind. Drake, genau.
Drake war's.
Ach, MW2, okay. Also das aktuelle Modern Warfare
hast du nicht gespielt, die Beta?
Ja, Mixer zieht nicht so hart, aber
er pusht krass auf Instagram und Twitter, irgendwas muss er ja machen.
Der kann jetzt ja auch nicht
der kann jetzt ja auch nicht von Mixer weg.
Zu sehr im Poker-Crime,
okay.
Ja gut, Poker ist wahrscheinlich eher
was fürs Hirn und nicht
so sehr für Reflexe und Hand-Augen-Koordination.
An den
Doc wird eh niemals jemand rankommen.
Von dem guck ich
immer mal ein paar Best-Of-Compilations,
das ist dann ganz lustig.
Mega was fürs Hirn, jaja.
Big Brain ist das.
Aber den Stream guck ich nicht gerne.
Leute, ich bin übelst lang on.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal 20, 30 Minuten
streamen, um meine neue
Unity-Media-Leitung auszuprobieren, das war's.
Ich geh jetzt off.
Ich geh jetzt pennen.
Und weil morgen früh bin ich ja schon wieder am Start.
Morgen früh müssen wir uns
Morgen früh ist ja der einzige
Tag, Leute, wo wir regulär streamen.
Also wo wir ein
festen Streaming-Zeitpunkt
haben. Sonntagsmorgens,
nachdem ich aufgestanden bin, da machen wir
immer Aufwach-Stream. Das machen wir schon seit,
einem Jahr oder so.
Wie viel, damit das
Stream weiterläuft?
Mindestens 300k YouTube-Subs.
Also wirft die Bots an. Okay, das war jetzt
MonkaTos. Wär ich wahrscheinlich gebannt.
Naja, aber ich geh jetzt
pennen. Bringst ein Brötchen mit.
Ich futter euch wieder was vor, ja.
ASMR-Eating-Sound-Stream.
Leute, übrigens, erst bevor ich off geh,
muss ich nochmal was loswerden.
Also erstens, der Chat hier auf Twitch
ist wirklich sehr nice.
Ich lese das immer gerne.
Und ohne den Chat wäre das auch nur die halbe
Sache. Und falls ihr es noch nicht
wusstet, wenn ihr
Amazon Prime habt, könnt ihr das ganze mit
Twitch verbinden.
Und ihr könnt dann einmal im Monat kostenlos
einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem
Prime-Sub unterstützen. Alle Vorteile
für euch, alle Vorteile für
den Streamer, ohne was bezahlen zu müssen.
Wenn schon Sellout, dann müssen wir richtig
Sellout machen.
Und ich kümmere mich mal
morgen drum, wenn der Stream
fertig ist. Erstens,
wir brauchen eine Sub-Badge.
Eine 3 Monate Sub-Badge.
Die meisten Leute hier sind ja, oder sagen wir mal so,
es gibt ja schon einige, die 3 Monate dabei sind.
Die haben immer noch den gleichen Keks, wie alle anderen.
Und ich kümmere mich mal um ein paar
Emotes. Ich meine, wir haben hier unsere
Standard-Emotes, aber ich habe mittlerweile, glaube ich,
18 Emote-Slots oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich guck mal kurz, guck mal kurz.
Ich habe massig viele Emote-Slots,
die einfach brach liegen,
ja. Da habe ich den Fedor
hosten. Wie streamt er jetzt?
Also, wenn ihr jetzt streamt, kann ich gerne hosten.
Also, wir haben jetzt
hier gerade
366 Subs.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt
Ja, wenn du jetzt on gehst,
hoste ich dich.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt Emotes,
muss ich mal kurz gucken,
Emote-Slots
17. Alter, das ist komplett
Ne, ne, 19.
19 mit den Tier 2 und Tier 3
Emote-Slots.
Ich habe,
ey, das ist wirklich übelst
Fail, ne.
Das ist übelst Fail.
Ich meine, ich habe ernsthaft
4 Emotes von
19 möglichen Emotes.
Das ist schon
billig, oder? Ja.
Also, wir machen den
Host jetzt an. Kein Ding.
Mach ein 3x3 Emote.
Ist wichtig, die Emote.
Jaja, hast du Recht. Gut benommen.
Nice.
Gut, sobald es hier
Refreshed, hoste ich dich.
Ah, jetzt. Nice, da ist er.
Okay, Leute, also ihr wolltet ja wahrscheinlich
schon immer mal Poker beim Fedor sehen.
Ähm.
Auf jeden Fall besser als Slot-Machine-Geschichten.
Was ich überhaupt nicht abkann. Poker ist einfach
für die Big-Brain-Leute.
Also, wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
So, jetzt muss ich nochmal gucken,
funktioniert das Hosten nicht. Ja, host.
Jetzt hosten wir ihn mal. Zack.
Okay, Leute.
Macht's gut. Bis denn. Tschüss.